du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement et la première d'entre
elles va être posée par le président
Mattei pour le groupe démocrate
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre Mesdames et Messieurs le
ministre chers collègues cette question
s'adresse à vous madame la Première
ministre depuis maintenant plus d'une
semaine nous débattons sur le projet des
réformes de retraite essentiel pour
préserver notre système par répartition
nous assistons démunies à une forme de
dérive de notre vie politique dans
laquelle comme un miroir grossissant de
notre société on peine à débattre du
fond et nous nous arrêtons trop souvent
à l'agression de notre corps même si je
dois souligner que les outrances de
certains de nos collègues nous nous
engage pas et on doit les dénoncer
je veux d'ailleurs par ces quelques mots
remercier salut Olivier du socle pour la
compétence et la dignité dont il fait
preuve dans ses débats
il n'y a pas de problème
vous le savez les députés démocrates
comme beaucoup dans cette hémicycle sont
particulièrement sensibles au respect de
la démocratie et la forme souvent vient
déterminer le fond pour nous l'une des
origines de ce mal et le mode de scrutin
majoritaire qui oblige à combattre à
l'adversaire lors de l'élection attitude
difficilement réparable pendant le monde
aucune véritable alliance de long terme
n'est possible si ce n'est des
arrangements électoraux ne sont jamais
bâties sur les accords de fond au-delà
de la stratégie adoptée par certains de
bloquer les débats par des milliers
d'amendements et une attitude qui nous
empêche de débattre d'éclairer les
Français sur les enjeux de la réforme
ainsi il nous semble urgent de mettre en
route la réforme de nos institutions
pour remettre le citoyen au centre du
jeu démocratique et nous permettre très
certainement de retrouver un débat
apaisé où chacune et chacun a les moyens
s'exprimer madame la Première ministre
pouvez-vous nous dire ce qu'il en est du
travail trans partisan sur nos
institutions pourriez-vous nous donner
un calendrier ainsi que la méthode
intégrant les parlementaires qui sera
retenu pour ses débats qui nous
semble-t-il sont de plus en plus urgents
et nécessaires pour sauvegarder notre
démocratie merci beaucoup président
Mattei la parole est à madame la
Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Jean-Paul Mattei
en juillet dernier dans ma déclaration
de politique générale j'avais affirmé la
volonté du gouvernement de répondre à la
crise démocratique que traverse notre
pays et plus largement notre continent
les raisons de cette crise sont
multiples elles sont notamment
institutionnelles la représentativité
est essentielle à la vitalité de notre
démocratie et je sais que ce sujet vous
tient à cœur et qu'il importe
particulièrement à votre groupe mais
réfléchir à nos modes de scrutin c'est
s'interroger plus globalement sur le
fonctionnement de nos institutions le
président de la République a lancé des
consultations sur la revitalisation de
notre démocratie et la réforme de nos
institutions comme il s'y était engagé
tous les groupes parlementaires seront
associés à cette réflexion
cet ensemble que nous devons construire
l'avenir de nos institutions
mais monsieur le Président Mattei votre
question vous l'avez dit s'inscrit dans
un contexte particulier
en aisant une assemblée sans majoritaire
absolue les Français ont envoyé un
message clair ils ont demandé des
compromis ils ont demandé des débats
fondés sur les arguments et les idées et
alors que votre assemblée discute en ce
moment même de notre projet pour les
retraites un texte important pour
l'avenir de notre pays que voient nos
compatriotes un débat empêché empêché
par la multiplication d'amendements qui
rendent impossible l'examen de la
totalité du texte
empêcher par la multiplication des
injures des invectives et hier même les
accusations les plus graves
empêchés par les attaques personnelles
odieux sans aucun lien avec le fond du
texte et je veux à mon tour redire tout
mon soutien à Olivier du soft
alors pensons aux Français qui nous ont
élus ce débat est-il à la hauteur
pensons aux Français qui n'ont pas été
votés ce débat est-il de nature à leur
faire retrouver le chemin des urnes la
démocratie c'est la diversité des
opinions et le respect de chacun la
démocratie c'est le refus de l'outrans
et l'attachement à la vérité
monsieur le président Jean-Paul Mattei
je partage votre inquiétude sur la tenue
des débats et sur l'image qu'elle donne
de la démocratie mais je veux croire
qu'il n'est pas encore trop tard pas
encore trop tard pour que les
amendements de blocage soient retirés
permettant un vrai débat de fond
pas encore trop tard pour un débat franc
mais jamais insultant pas encore trop
tard pour renoncer aux outrances être à
la hauteur de la mission que nous ont
confié les Français il est encore temps
de montrer que nous sommes capables de
nous opposer parfois vivement mais
toujours dans le respect des uns et des
autres si nous ne dit parvenons il y
aura qu'une seule gagnante la démocratie
je vous remercie je vous remercie madame
la Première ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Thomas ménager
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
la semaine dernière monsieur le ministre
Gabriel Attal a indiqué que nous étions
face à un dilemme la réforme des
retraites ou la faillite votre
gouvernement entretient un discours
défaitiste un discours de perdant mais
surtout un discours emprunt de
contre-vérité pour faire peur aux
Français la fausse promesse d'une
retraite minimale à 1200 euros pour tous
est un exemple criant de vos nombreux
mensonges depuis 2017 Emmanuel Macron
privilégie les Ultra riches qui ont
gagné 10 à 20 fois plus que les bas
revenus du fait de sa politique
d'injustice sociale en bref Emmanuel
Macron a créé 600 milliards de dettes en
5 ans et demande aujourd'hui aux classes
populaires et aux classes moyennes de
payer les pots cassés de son incapacité
à gérer le pays avec cette réforme des
retraites
inutiles et injustes
l'argent pourtant il y en a il y en a
dans les poches des spéculateurs dont
vous refusez de taxer les super profits
je pense à Total qui a réalisé un
bénéfice net record de 20 milliards
d'euros en 2022 il y en a aussi à Bercy
puisqu’entre 2021 et 2022 poussé par une
inflation record les recettes fiscales
et sociales ont augmenté de 86 milliards
d'euros et oui quand les Français paient
plus cher leur carburant ou leur caddie
de course dans les supermarchés à Amilly
dans ma circonscription par exemple
l'état s'enrichit avec de la TVA mais
vous faites le choix de ne redistribuer
que des miettes par des chèques et des
risques tournent temporaires et
inefficaces avec Marine Le Pen nous
avons des solutions structurelles pour
rendre aux Français leur argent
notamment en baissant la TVA sur
l'énergie et sur les carburants ou en
sortant du marché européen de
l'électricité nous devons également
remettre de l'ordre dans nos finances
publiques en taxant les super profits et
en supprimant le minimum vieillesse pour
les étrangers n'ayant jamais cotisé en
France tout cela demande de la volonté
politique mais vous préférez céder à la
facilité en demandant aux Français de
travailler deux ans de plus aussi madame
la Première ministre quand comptez-vous
rendre aux Français leur argent
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie des Finances la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique
vous seriez plus crédible dans votre
défense du pouvoir d'achat des classes
moyennes si vous aviez voté l'indemnité
carburant travailleur qui bénéficie à
toutes les classes moyennes notre pays
vous seriez plus crédible si vous aviez
voté le plafonnement des prix du gaz
vous soyez plus crédible si vous avez
voté le bouclier qui protège tous les
ménages les plus modestes contre
l'augmentation des prix de l'électricité
vous soyez plus crédible si vous aviez
lu le rapport de la Cour des comptes qui
établit noir sur blanc que la baisse des
thé vert n'est pas efficace qu'elle
ruine l'État et qu'elle ne bénéficie pas
né au classement moyenne nioclas
populaire
vous commentez monsieur ménager nous
nous agissons et avec le président de la
République avec la Premier ministre avec
tout le gouvernement avec cette majorité
nous avons des résultats dont nous
sommes fiers nous avons le taux d'emploi
le plus élevé depuis 50 ans dans notre
pays et le travail c'est le pouvoir
d'achat c'est de la rémunération c'est
de l'activité pour tous nous avons le
taux de chômage le plus bas depuis 15
ans dans notre pays c'est la vraie
avancée sociale nous avons une
croissance qui est solide et que vous le
vouliez ou non monsieur ménager nous
avons le taux d'inflation parmi les plus
faibles la zone euro grâce à l'action de
cette majorité et grâce au burkeli
énergétique que vous n'avez pas voté
voté nos propositions soutenez notre
action et vous aurez les résultats que
nous nous avons obtenus au service de
nos compatriotes
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Benjamin Lucas pour le groupe
écologiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre vous avez perdu la
bataille des retraites vous l'avez perdu
le 19 juin dernier quand les Françaises
et les Français ont refusé Emmanuel
Macron les pleins pouvoirs dans cette
assemblée pour appliquer son programme
présidentiel vous l'avez perdu dans la
rue devant un mouvement social uni
puissant vous l'avez perdu dans
l'opinion publique comme en atteste
quotidiennement les sondages qui nous
parviennent c'est le résultat de votre
pédagogie plus vous expliquez la réforme
plus les Français la comprennent plus
les Français la comprennent plus ils la
rejette et la combatte avec nous car oui
les Françaises et les Français comme
nous aspirent à travailler mieux à
travailler moins oui à travailler moins
pour travailler tous et nous célébrions
hier d'ailleurs l'anniversaire des 35
heures mesure jadis soutenu par Olivier
du socle l'actuel ministre du Travail
alors madame la Première ministre ma
question est simple il n'est pas trop
tard pour apaiser le pays et éviter le
blocage quand allez-vous renoncer à
voler aux françaises et aux Français
deux années de vie deux années de vie en
bonne santé quand allez-vous retirer
votre réforme
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le député lucarne nous poser
des questions je vous en êtes aucune
nous avons un système de retraite qui
est déficiable 12 milliards 5 en 2027 de
15 milliards en 2030 de 20 milliards en
2035 et de 25 milliards en 2030 nous
avons un rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites qui dit qui
nous ne faisons rien le niveau de vie
des retraités de la BC par rapport à la
population active est-ce que vous
promettez au retraités actuel la
pauvreté et aux retraités futures
l'absence de retraite
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur Lucas
monsieur le ministre on vous entendant
je mesure que ce qui nous oppose n'est
pas simplement une divergence comptable
pas seulement une opposition sociale
c'est un véritable combat moral car oui
nous nous considérons qu'il est
profondément immoral de voler aux
françaises et aux Français deux années
de vie et deux années de vie en bonne
santé de précariser les femmes celles et
ceux qui ont des métiers pénibles
pendant que à coup d'offrande fiscale
vous permettait une infime minorité de
privilégier dans ce pays d'accumuler les
richesses et de s'accaparer les
ressources monsieur le ministre voilà la
réalité aujourd'hui du débat qui nous
oppose un débat d'égalité un débat de
justice et bien nous entendons que vous
êtes droit dans vos bottes comme jadis
hier d'autres l'été croyez moi à la fin
vous retirez cette réforme
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur le ministre du Travail
qui parfois me stupéfait cela fait 10
jours 10 jours que vous défendez des
amendements là pour défendre le régime
spécial de la Banque de France ailleurs
pour supprimer un alinéa technique là
encore pour enlever un adverbe là après
pour remplacer le nom d'index par l'idée
d'une feuille de salade autant
d'amendements qui n'ont strictement rien
à voir rien avec le sujet rien avec
l'intérêt des Français rien n'avait avec
la sauvegarde du système de retraite la
réalité monsieur le député vous savez ce
qui nous repose ce qui nous sépare c'est
pas une question de moralité c'est une
question c'est une question de
responsabilité la responsabilité de
préserver un système par répartition la
responsabilité de préserver un système
de solidité de solidarité
intergénérationnelle la responsabilité
de préserver le pouvoir d'achat des
Français et en particulier des retraités
la responsabilité de prendre des
décisions quand il le faut pour que
demain elle ne soit pas plus difficile
encore à assumer
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Michel Castellani
pour le groupe liote
merci de m'avoir présidente ma question
s'adresse madame la Première ministre si
on en croit les trois ambassadeurs de
l'épagne salariale nommés par le
gouvernement 9 milliards ont été
distribués en 2020 au salarié au titre
de l'intéressement 8 milliards pour la
participation et 3 pour d'autres
dispositifs soit 21 milliards au total
alors que les actionnaires en ont perçu
en 2022 ce sont 56 millions et demi qui
ont été versés aux actionnaires auxquels
s'ajoutent 23 milliards 7 verset sous
forme de rachat d'action il faut bien
sûr se réjouir devant les entreprises
prospérer et dégager de substantiels
bénéfices et non demeure pas moins que
ces données interpellent elles posent
une fois de plus la question de la
répartition de la valeur ajoutée de
l'entreprise plus largement de la
richesse nationale de l'équilibre entre
économie réelle économie financière et
aussi de façon indirecte de la frontière
entre esprit d'entreprise et spéculation
c'est 80 milliards distribués au moment
où nous débattons de l'avenir du système
de retraite soulèvent de façon aiguë la
question bien des fois posée jamais
résolu sur le fond du dividende de
salarié et de la participation des
travailleurs au bénéfice des entreprises
ma question est donc la suivante madame
la Première ministre quelle mesure
comptez-vous prendre pour que le
travailleur soit mieux rémunéré en
bénéficiant d'une part plus consistante
des bénéfices distribués je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
le président
monsieur le député Michel Castellani je
vous rejoins en tout point il est
essentiel que la France qui a un partage
de la valeur entre le capital et le
travail qui est stable depuis 20 ans ce
qui est un cas unique parmi les pays
développés dans tous les autres pays
développés la rémunération du capital
est allée plus vite que la rémunération
du travail a créé un sentiment
d'injustice et des inégalités nous
voulons non seulement que cette
répartition reste équitable mais nous
voulons l'améliorer au profit du salarié
au profit de ceux qui travaillent nous
voulons que le partage de la valeur soit
le grand combat de cette majorité en
2023 et dans les années qui viennent je
voudrais d'abord saluer le travail qui a
été fait par les partenaires sociaux sur
ce sujet
ils ont obtenu et eux sans crier sans
hurler sans injurier les partenaires
sociaux ont obtenu un accord sur le
partage de la valeur que je tiens saluer
et qui sera retranscrit par voie
législatives pour que tous les salariés
puissent en bénéficier dès la semaine
prochaine nous allons travailler avec la
majorité sur la manière d'améliorer
l'intéressement de développer la
participation de développer
l'actionnariat salarié pour que la
France reste en tête des pays développés
où le nombre de salariés actionnaires
plus de 3 millions et le plus important
de tous les pays développés nous créons
du travail nous créons l'emploi nous
approchons du plein emploi en France
mais nous ne nous satisfaisons pas de
cette réussite nous voulons que le
travail soit digne soit bien rémunéré
permettent à chacun de garantir sa vie
je vous le redis monsieur Castellani le
partage de la valeur sera le combat de
la majorité dans les mois qui viennent
je vous remercie monsieur Castellane
monsieur Castellani allez-y
je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
pour votre réponse nous savons tous que
cette peur de difficulté sociale nous
avons le devoir d'améliorer le lien
social et de renforcer la valeur travail
il n'est pas juste que les personnes
soient rémunérées en millions d'euros
annuel alors que tant d'autres trimes
pour des salaires qui n'excèdent que
péniblement les 1000 euros mensuels
c'est cette question c'est une question
que nous devons traiter sans volonté
punitive mais dans un esprit de
solidarité je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à Madame constance le grip
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre
l'Économie des Finances de la Fuente
industrielle et numérique l'heure semble
enfin venu d'une politique industrielle
européenne ambitieuse si nous voulons
que l'Union européenne reste un acteur
industriel majeur notamment dans le
secteur des industries d'avenir et des
industries vertes nous n'avons plus le
choix nous devons tout mettre en œuvre
pour atteindre l'indépendance
industrielle et la souveraineté
européenne nous avons nous Européens
ensemble plusieurs défis à affronter les
défis énergétiques environnementaux
climatiques économique les défis de la
concurrence des loyale d'acteurs
extra-européens et la course effrénée à
l'innovation technologique souvent
subventionnée massivement par ces
acteurs extra-européens enfin le défi du
renforcement du protectionnisme
américain notamment avec l'entrée en
vigueur prochaine de l'inflation
face à plan américain massif visant à
soutenir les industries vertes aux
États-Unis la riposte européenne
s'organise vous avez vous-même porté
monsieur le ministre avec votre
homologue allemand une contribution
commune proposant des mesures fortes et
sans précédent et vous avez également eu
l'occasion de les présenter à Washington
récemment tous les deux vendredi dernier
le Conseil européen des chefs d'État et
du gouvernement a adopté le pacte
industriel vert préparé par la
Commission européenne et pour lequel
l'engagement de la France est tout
particulièrement l'investissement
personnel et constant du président
Macron ont été absolument décisifs
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
détailler les principales mesures de la
riposte industrielle européenne est-ce
que le sursaut industriel européen est
là je vous remercie merci beaucoup
ma chère collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
madame
[Musique]
députée le grip en 2017 le président de
la République est bien le Macron avait
appelé l'Union européenne à un sursaut
pour défendre sa souveraineté et son
indépendance industrielle
nous avons gagné une première bataille
au cours du premier quinquennat DU BELL
Macron en ouvrant la voie la création de
nouvelles filières industrielles comme
les batteries électriques c'est très
concrètement des milliers d'emplois qui
vont être créés dans le nord de la
France en particulier qui vont garantir
notre indépendance en matière de
fournitures de batterie électrique et
qui vont nous permettre d'amorcer cette
reconquête industrielle qui est au cœur
de notre projet nous venons de gagner
nous venons de gagner vendredi dernier
Conseil européen sous l'impulsion
d'Emmanuel Macron une deuxième bataille
qui est de mettre en place un plan
européen pour l'industrie verte qui soit
capable de rivaliser avec les décisions
américaines nous pourrons mettre en
place des crédits d'impôts pour soutenir
notre industrie nous pourrons augmenter
les subventions nous aurons une clause
d'alignement qui permettra lorsque les
États-Unis proposent un certain montant
pour faire venir une entreprise sur leur
territoire de rivaliser avec ce montant
de proposer exactement le même montant
pour qu'il y ait une compétition
équitable entre le territoire américain
et le territoire européen et nous avons
enfin décidé qu'il y aurait une
simplification massive des projets
intérêts collectifs européens pour
qu'ils aillent plus vite et qu'ils
donnent des résultats notamment sur le
déploiement d'hydrogène il reste une
troisième bataille à livrer que nous
voulons livrer avec après un ministre et
avec la ministre de l'Énergie Agnès
panure une hachée c'est la bataille du
marché européen de l'énergie toutes ces
décisions prises sous l'autorité du
Président de la République qui nous ont
permis depuis 6 ans d'ouvrir plus
d'usines que nous n'enfermons de recréer
des emplois industriels dans un pays
qu'on a perdu par centaines de milliers
doit s'appuyer sur une énergie
disponible peu cher nucléaire ou
renouvelable cela suppose de découpler
le prix du gaz du prix de l'électricité
nucléaire et de payer notre énergie
nucléaire au prix de l'électricité
nucléaire c'est notre prochain combat
nous le gagnerons comme les deux
précédents
merci beaucoup monsieur
la parole est à Monsieur michel
Herbillon pour le groupe les
républicains merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre Bruno Le Maire en matière de
politique économique le gouvernement
n'est jamais avare d'éloges sur ses
résultats et vous venez de nous en
donner une illustration depuis le début
de cet après-midi pourtant nous
franchissons à niveau historique dans
des vêtements et nous sommes déjà les
vices champion du monde des prélèvements
obligatoires et des dépenses publiques
et voilà qu'à nouveau record vient de
tomber celui du déficit commercial qui a
doublé en 2022
164 milliards d'euros du jamais vu la
pire performance des pays de l'Union
Européenne dans le même temps
l’allemagne affiche un excédent de 76
milliards d'euros tandis que l'Italie
est en train de renouer avec une balance
commerciale positive bien sûr une grande
part de cette dégradation s'explique par
la hausse des prix de l'énergie du
pétrole du gaz que nous apportons mais
aussi de l'électricité car oui alors que
la France exportait jadis son
électricité nous avons été contraints
dans n'importe quel grand frais tant
vous avez affaibli notre parc nucléaire
et notre souveraineté énergétique mais
tout cela c'est l'arbre qui cache la
forêt la réalité c'est qu'en fait la
part de la France dans les exportations
mondiales à diminué de moitié de 5 à 2,5
la réalité c'est l'effondrement de notre
industrie manufacturière tombée pour la
première fois sous les 10% du PIB le
bilan est simple en dépit des forts trop
insuffisant sur les impôts de production
votre politique de réindustrie
réindustrialisation pardon ne produit
pas de résultats et nous entreprises
manquent encore de compétitivité
monsieur le ministre votre majorité est
au pouvoir depuis six ans et Emmanuel
Macron auparavant secrétaire général
adjoint l'Élysée puis ministre de
l'Économie de l'Industrie les depuis 11
ans vous ne pouvez pas vous exonérer de
votre responsabilité
en reportant toujours la faute sur les
autres alors allez-vous enfin assumez de
défendre notre souveraineté industrielle
pour permettre à la France d'être
compétitive et à nous entreprises de
regagner des parts de marché à
l'étranger merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Olivier belge
de ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
extérieur de l'attractivité et des
Français de l'étranger merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Herbillon alors nous serons d'accord sur
une chose effectivement la balance des
biens a atteint un déficit record à -164
milliards d'euros ce n'est pas le
déficit commercial car le déficit
commercial prend en compte également la
balance des services et la balance des
revenus or la balance des services à un
excédent record de plus de 50 milliards
d'euros et la balance des services un
excédent lui aussi record pardon des
revenus de plus de 31 milliards en ce
qui concerne la balance des biens
c'est dégradé vous l'avez dit vous-même
le déficit a doublé à cause de l'énergie
notre parc nucléaire était en partie à
l'arrêt parce qu'il fallait rattraper
les deux années de maintenance qui n'ont
pas pu être fait durant la pandémie qui
a et parce que nous avons également sur
les marchés un prix de l'énergie qui a
doublé cette part conjoncturelle du
déficit s'effacera d'elle-même il y a en
revanche et vous avez raison et vous
avez raison une part structurelle du
déficit qui est du d'un côté à la
désindustrialisation du pays pendant 25
ans cette désindustrialisation
aujourd'hui elle s'est inversée nous
sommes dans une phase de réhab de
réindustrialisation avec plus d'usines
qui ouvrent que d'usine qui ferme nous
avons des projets très concrets les
semi-conducteurs accroll nous avons le
paracétamol dans l'Isère nous avons le
lithium dans l'Allier ou dans le
Bas-Rhin nous sommes devenus le premier
pays en terre d'accueil des
investissements en Europe la première
place 1222 projet qui crée des emplois
dans l'ensemble des territoires et nous
avons et nous avons une deuxième part
qui est la part effectivement des PME
qui sont insuffisamment exportatrices
même si nous avons aujourd'hui plus de
144 000 entreprises exportatrices se
sont CPME que nous devons envoyer à
l'export ce sont les marchés que nous
allons conquérir c'est le travail de ce
gouvernement merci
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est un Monsieur Emmanuel
Fernandez pour le groupe français
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre dans un tweet hier en fin
d'après-midi vous souhaitiez que nous
soyons à la hauteur des Français qui
nous ont élus et du débat démocratique
qu'ils attendent et bien voici une
occasion de prouver que vous l'êtes
madame borne pouvez-vous affirmer ici
que votre projet de réforme des
retraites propose une pension minimale à
1200 euros pour tous et si tel n'est pas
le cas nous dire combien de personnes
seraient concernées il s'agit d'un
budget rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale vous devez savoir combien de
retraités toucheraient les 1200 euros
publié vos chiffres cachés le 11 janvier
votre porte-parole Olivier Véran
déclarait 2 millions de retraités
actuels verront leur retraite majorée à
1200 euros brut confirmez-vous ce
chiffre le 6 février votre Ministre de
l'économie Bruno Le Maire annonçait la
retraite minimum à 1200 euros y compris
pour celles et ceux qui sont déjà à la
retraite
madame Chapa messieurs à tal et Riester
et j'en passe tous membres de votre
gouvernement tous ont colportait le même
mensonge ainsi que nombre de députés
macronistes oui vous mentez vous
dissimulez la vérité c'est celle qui a
clairement expliqué l'économiste Michael
Zemmour il n'y aura pas de pension
minimale garantie à 1200 euros y compris
pour les carrières complètes la réalité
c'est celle décrite par les économistes
de l'Institut des politiques publiques
moins de 10% des nouveaux retraités sont
potentiellement concernés par
l'augmentation maximale de 100 euros
permettant d'approcher les 1200 euros et
concernant les retraités actuels les
trois quarts ne seraient pas concernés
par la revalorisation alors ça c'est les
mensonges pour faire avaler un projet
injuste publier vos chiffres cachés
dites-nous combien de personnes
toucheraient les 1200 euros soyez comme
vous le demandez à la hauteur du débat
démocratique que le pays attend
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion merci merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame monsieur le député
Fernandez
nous allons Hernandez pardonner moi nous
allons revenir
quelques mois en arrière pendant
l'élection de la campagne présidentielle
à la fois le premier tour vous avez
participé mais aussi le deuxième tour
que vous avez moins concerné
le président de la République
les présidents de la République a dit
vous savez j'ai tout mon temps j'ai
plein d'autres questions je pourrais
revenir j'ai la nuit entière pour
répondre à vos questions et Madame
guette ça fait 8 jours que je vous
entends crier ça ne me change pas
vraiment à cet instant du débat
le président de la République a pris un
engagement et cet engagement nous le
tenons il a dit que pour tout assurer
qu'on aurait une carrière complète au
niveau du SMIC il y aurait une garantie
de retraite à 85% du SMIC ce principe il
avait été posé en 2003 personne ne l'a
jamais mise en œuvre nous le faisons et
nous le faisons avec un index qui va
faire une indexation sur le SMIC qui va
permettre de tenir cet engagement dans
le temps combien de personnes cela va
concerner ça va concerner 200 000
nouveaux retraités sur les 800 000
nouveaux retraités chaque année un
retraité sur quatre aurait une pension
meilleur grâce à notre réforme que sans
la réforme en votant contre la réforme
vous interdisez un député sur quatre et
puis modeste de voir leur pension
revaloriser et lorsqu'on regarde les 17
millions de retraités actuels 17
millions de retraités actuels un million
800000 un million 800 villes vont
bénéficier d'une robe à l'organisation
et là aussi vous votez contre vous votez
contre vous refusez que des retraités
avec 850 900 950 euros et tu ne
revalorisation qui ira de 50 60 et
jusqu'à 100 euros peut-être parce que
dans votre esprit vous considérez que 60
euros ça n'est pas grand chose pour eux
au contraire c'est essentiel ceux qui
s'occupent des retraités les plus
modestes et cette majorité ceux qui vont
rebaloriser les petites retraites c'est
cette majorité ceux qui revalorisent les
retraites actuelles c'est cette majorité
comme nous l'avions fait avec le minimum
vieillesse il y a quelques mois
merci ma famille
combien à 1200 euros par mois
la parole est un monsieur Jérôme Guedj
pour le groupe socialiste
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Franck Riester ministre du
gouvernement qui nous dit la vérité sur
la réforme des retraites
les privilégiés nos employés
disent cela est inévitable mais l'ordre
social actuel est condamné par la
conscience collective cette phrase elle
est de Jean Jaurès qui pardon de vous
contredire madame la Présidente était un
socialiste authentique un républicain
conséquent un député respecté quand il
défendait Dreyfus la laïcité et la
première loi c'est les retraites
ouvrières c'est cette confiance c'est
cette confiance collective qui s'exprime
dans le pays par le rejet massif de
votre réforme des retraites car
voyez-vous les Français ne vous croient
pas non votre réforme n'est pas
inévitable c'est un choix politique je
dirais idéologique qui fait que pour la
première fois pour une réforme des
retraites vous avez décidé de ne pas
mettre à contribution les entreprises
mais uniquement de faire porter l'effort
sur les sols salariés nous nous avons
toute une palette de solutions pour
taxer les super profits les dividendes
le patrimoine les retraites chapeau les
gratuite pour supprimer les niches
sociales jugées inefficaces alors vous
nous direz comme la fée Gabriel Attal
que nous taxons taxons taxons mais c'est
pour mieux faire oublier votre obsession
qui est exonéron exonérant exonérant
nous nous vous disons partagez partagez
partagez entendez le gouverneur de la
Banque de France qui exhorte à ce qu'on
arrête la course à la baisse d'impôts au
nom de la solidarité vous voulez une
solution en 2030 avec vos propres
hypothèses il y aura un excédent de
l'assurance chômage de 20 milliards
d'euros et un déficit du de l'Assurance
retraite de 15 milliards d'euros vous ne
pensez pas qu'on pourrait compenser et
éviter de cette impôts de deux ans sur
la vie sur l'ensemble de notre citoyens
votre deuxième postulat c'est de faire
travailler plus pour produire plus mais
que faites-vous de tous ces retraités
qui participent à la vie sociale du pays
vous allez retirer deux années de
retraité qu'on la garde des enfants et
merci
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du stop
après-midi du travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion merci à madame la
Présidente il y a un débat sur les
retraites qui durent depuis maintenant
plusieurs jours et c'est l'occasion de
répondre à des questions récentes
nous aurons je crois dans quelques
heures quelques minutes peut-être
l'occasion de terminer l'examen de
l'article 2 du projet de loi après 10
jours et d'ouvrir une discussion sur un
certain nombre d'amendements que vous
présentez comme autant de solutions
alternatives au financement des
retraites mais regardez de plus près que
proposez-vous nous avons un déficit qui
est structurel 12 milliards et demi par
an dès 2027 c'est demain nous avons un
déficit de 13 milliards et demi par an
en 2030 de 20 milliards en 2035 de 25 en
2040 si nous ne faisons rien je l'ai dit
je le répète ce sont 50000 150 milliards
de déficits accumulés sur les 10 ans qui
viennent et vous vont nous dites taxer
les super profits faites en sorte que la
recette exceptionnelle d'une année d'une
année
soit la solution à la dépense
structurelle d'une décennie ça ne tient
tout simplement pas la route ça ne tient
pas la route et ça n'est pas sérieux et
vous nous reprochez finalement de
vouloir financer le système de retraite
par le recours au travail mais admettez
avec moi que nous sommes peut-être allés
à bonne école l'augmentation de la durée
de cotisation de 40 de 43 ans qui la
voté c'est vous c'est moi en 2013 en
2013 au début du quinquennat de François
Hollande c'est ça aussi la réalité de la
réforme que nous mettons en place vous
me dites monsieur Guedj ce que vous
n'allez pas voté c'est vrai vous étiez
déjà dans le camp de la Fronde vous
savez la fronde c'est ce qui va éviter
cette majorité parce que justement ceux
qui ont connu la fronde savent qu'il n'y
a rien de pire pour facturer une
majorité et condamner à l'impuissance
politique celles et ceux qui sont
confrontés je terminerai par un mot
monsieur Gadge parce que nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir tout à l'heure
vous avez ouvert votre question par une
citation de jeunesse elle est belle mais
c'est aussi une formidable mise en abyme
sur la nouvelle infection dont vous
faites preuve
[Applaudissements]
Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
monsieur le ministre au moment où la
nouvelle carte scolaire est publiée la
question du comptage des effectifs
refait surface et demeure une fois de
plus un sujet d'inquiétude majeur
lorsqu'il s'agit d'évoquer le maintien
de poste ou de classe en zone rurale
dans ma circonscription en Ardèche je
peux citer l'exemple de deux communes
Désaignes et saint-jorde deux communes
ou des postes vont être supprimés car
l'Académie a jugé que les très petites
sections ne rentrait pas dans le
comptage des effectifs globaux ceci au
motifs qu'elles ne sont pas situés en
zone de montagne alors qu'elles sont en
zone rurale et même de revitalisation
rurale pourtant l'intégration des très
petites sections dans le comptage des
effectifs a été tranché par votre
ministère dans une intervention au Sénat
en février 2022
monsieur le ministre cette situation
déstabilise grandement nos communes
rurales combien de fois faudra-t-il
encore trancher sur les critères de
comptage des effectifs combien
d'enseignants de parents d'élèves de
maire dans nos communes rurales
faudra-t-il encore rassurer chaque année
les fermetures de classe pénalisent les
familles et les enfants des territoires
ruraux ce n'est pas acceptable c'est sur
ces territoires que l'éducation
nationale doit mobiliser et encourager
les partenariats avec tous les acteurs
locaux l'avenir de notre jeunesse est
primordial donnons aux enfants des
territoires ruraux les mêmes chances
qu'à tous nos enfants l'égalité des
chances partout et pour tous c'est le
combat de notre majorité c'est pourquoi
monsieur le ministre je vous demande
quelles actions allez vous mettre en
place pour garantir le maintien des
classes pérenniser nos écoles et
réaffirmer les directives du ministère
sur le comptage des très petites
sections je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur papenda
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
d'elle-grière votre question s'inscrit
évidemment dans le contexte général
d'une baisse des effectifs scolaires
c'est vrai à l'échelle nationale c'est
vrai également en ce qui concerne votre
département de l'Ardèche qui comptera
dans le premier degré 239 élèves en
moins à la rentrée
2023 sur votre question précise de la
prise en compte des élèves de moins de 3
ans dans l'élaboration de la carte
scolaire la politique du ministère n'a
pas changé en effet les enfants de moins
de 3 ans peuvent être accueillis en
école maternelle dans le cadre des très
petites sections c'est vrai
particulièrement en zone d'éducation en
éducation prioritaire et également dans
les territoires ruraux mais nous ne
prenons en compte les enfants de moins
de 3 ans que dans le cadre dans leur
scolarisation nous ne prenons pas en
compte l'ensemble des enfants de moins
de 3 ans pour élaborer la carte scolaire
celle-ci se fait en prenant en compte
l'effectivité de la scolarisation des
enfants de moins de 3 ans et donc nous
nous
appelions pas sur un recensement général
mais sur la prise en compte des très
petites sections des écoles maternelles
le travail est en train de se faire avec
les élus locaux et avec les directions
académiques pour ouvrir et fermeture et
fermer les classes en fonction des
réalités locales et nous allons procéder
d'ici au mois de juin aux ajustements
nécessaires il y aura des ajustements en
fonction des réalités locales et en
fonction des échanges avec les élus
locaux les élus dans les zones rurales
avec qui nous échangeons et j'en profite
pour les remercier
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Xavier Breton pour
le groupe les républicains merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de la Culture madame
la ministre de très nombreuses personnes
ont été choquées par les menaces que
vous avez formulées à l'encontre des
chaînes C8 et c'est news en menaçant ces
chaînes de ne pas renouveler leur
fréquence vous avez bien sûr heurter les
téléspectateurs qui trouvent une autre
manière de s'informer
mais vous avez aussi choqué tous ceux
qui sont attachés au pluralisme de
l'information vous avez scandalisé tous
ceux qui défendent cette grande liberté
constitutionnelle qui est la liberté
d'expression dans une démocratie sur un
sujet aussi sensible que l'information
un gouvernement se doit d'observer une
stricte réserve en aucun cas il ne peut
prendre parti et c'est pourtant ce que
vous avez fait et en le faisant non
seulement vous avez menacé la liberté
d'expression mais vous avez aussi remis
en cause l'indépendance de l'arcome
l'autorité de régulation de la
communication audiovisuelle et numérique
normalement l'arcome devrait être une
autorité publique indépendante mais par
vos propos madame la ministre vous
discréditer et son indépendance et son
impartialité
alors madame la ministre de la Culture
allez-vous observer à l'avenir une
stricte neutralité pour respecter la
liberté d'expression et le pluralisme de
l'information
je vous remercie mon cher collègues la
parole est à Madame Rima Abdul Malak
ministre de la Culture
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
breton alors soit vous avez pas écouté
mon interview soit vous tenez absolument
à déformer mes propos peut-être pour
détourner le regard de ce que sont les
faits et de ce qu'est le cadre existant
que je vais essayer de rappeler ici
est-ce que la loi de 1986 qui est une
loi très importante pour notre
démocratie prévoit des obligations pour
les chaînes qui sont les chaînes de la
TNT qui ont des fréquences gratuites oui
est-ce que
si ces chaînes ne respectent pas les
obligations est-ce qu'elles peuvent
s'exposer à des sanctions la réponse est
oui est-ce que c'est au CSA devenu
l'arcom de prononcer ses sanctions la
réponse est encore oui je n'ai jamais
dit le contraire j'ai toujours rappelé
ce qui est relevé du rôle de l'arcom
alors quelles sont ses obligations ça me
semble important de le redire ici dans
cette émission
et ça s'applique à toutes les chaînes
absolument toutes les chaînes
oui oui faut les rappeler traiter les
affaires judiciaires avec mesure
assurer l'expression des différents
points de vue sur les sujets qui prêtent
à controverse respecter l'indépendance
de l'information notamment à l'égard des
intérêts économiques des actionnaires ou
des annonceurs lutter contre les
discriminations respecter la dignité des
personnes etc quel est le constat
aujourd'hui et vous me donnez l'occasion
de compléter les réponses que j'ai
faites à l'interview que vous mentionnez
prenons les interventions de l'arcom
elles sont publiques depuis 2019
vis-à-vis des chaînes de la TNT qui
bénéficient ces fréquences gratuites et
donc ils doivent respecter ces
obligations qui vont avec depuis 2019
deux interventions pour France
Télévisions 0 pour TF1 0 pour M6 une
vingtaine pour les deux chaînes que vous
mentionnez donc monsieur le député il
n'a jamais été question d'interdire tel
ou telle chaîne ou de menacer telle ou
telle chaîne ou s'immiscer dans les
pouvoirs du régulateur qui est
strictement indépendant absolument
indépendant merci Madame rappeler les
termes de la loi
ferraille de censure on n'a pas la même
définition de la merci madame la
ministre mais mon cher collègue oui
madame la ministre votre meilleur
réponse aurait été de prendre acte de
dire effectivement il y a une stricte
neutralité qui s'impose à moi en tant
que ministre j'entends votre question et
je ne vais pas plus loin le problème
c'est que vous plus vous parlez plus
vous vous enfoncez parce
qu'effectivement vous rappelez un cadre
légal mais ensuite vous êtes là
effectivement en menaçant et je crois
que ce qu'il faut faire attention parce
que si effectivement il y a des chaînes
de télévision qui ne correspondent pas à
la pensée unique à la bienséance etc que
vous voulez imposer et bien il y a une
réaction on sait que les libertés sont
mises en danger dans notre pays ça a été
la liberté de manifestation la liberté
de culte la liberté de communication
faisons attention merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Émeline carbidy
pour le groupe
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre du Travail
monsieur du stop pour tenter de diluer
l'injustice de votre réforme vous avez
annoncé aux Français à longueur de
plateau télé qu'il pourrait bénéficier à
minima d'une retraite à 1200 euros alors
que les Français ne sont pas dupes et
qu'ils se masse dans la rue par millions
de plus en plus nombreux au fil des
manifestations vous revenez sur vos
promesses et on vous surprend à lire les
conditions écrites en tout petit
caractère au bas d'un contrat que nous
ne voulons pas signer vous annoncez
désormais que les 1200 euros
s'entendraient brut ce qui n'est pas
sans causer une vraie différence dans le
portefeuille des ménages
vous affirmez également qu'il faudra
pour y avoir droit avoir travaillé 43
ans en ayant été payé au smic nous vous
avons demandé à plusieurs reprises
combien de personnes pourront
véritablement bénéficier des 1200 euros
vous refusez de répondre précisément à
vos mensonges monsieur le ministre
s'ajoute un deuxième mensonge par
omission celui-ci contrairement à ce que
vous asseyez les travailleurs les plus
pauvres ce à temps partiels qui
survivent de salaire de misère ne
comprennent pas et n'accepte PAS de se
voir imposer deux années de plus pour
une retraite tout aussi misérable je
pense aux Atsems aux aesh aux
auxiliaires de vie au saisonnier
agricole pour ne citer que
parmi ceux-là je pense particulièrement
à mes compatriotes des Outre-mer à qui
vaut 1200 euros ne pourront pas
s'appliquer non seulement parce qu'il
souffre de carrière hachées de temps
partiel subit de revenus en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté mais surtout parce
qu'il vous a fallu attendre près d'un
demi-siècle pour aligner leur SMIC sur
celui de l'Hexagone alors monsieur le
ministre comme vous ne voulez pas nous
dire combien de personnes bénéficieront
des 1200 euros pouvez-vous au moins nous
dire combien n'en bénéficieront pas en
France hexagonale comme en hexagone
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du
sorte ministre du Travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion merci madame le
Président Madame la Députée je risque
parfois de répéter certains arguments
vous me pardonnerez mais je vais
apporter aussi quelques éléments de
réponse très spécifique à votre question
et notamment sur des cas que vous avez
évoqué le président de la République
l'addie je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
l'engagement de 85% du SMIC c'est pour
une carrière complète au niveau du SMIC
aujourd'hui 42 annuités demain 43
annuités et c'est cet objectif que nous
poursuivons de garantir ce niveau
minimum de pension à 85% du SPIC pour
une carrière complète vous me dites
madame la députée combien de personnes
cela va représenter je l'ai dit c'est un
retraité sur quatre qui bénéficiera
d'une revalorisation de pension et
1.800000 de retraités sur les 17
millions de retraités actuels qui vont
bénéficier d'une revalorisation aussi
sur le million 800000 retraités actuels
un million et 100000 lois traités
actuels qui vont avoir une
revalorisation de leur pension
50% d'entre eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pardon mais
moi je
allez on écoute le ministre s'il vous
plaît
j'entends madame guette qui me traduit
la question donc j'attends qu'elle aille
au bout
je disais madame caseville est-ce que je
tenais apporter une réponse précise à sa
question
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Paul cristal
pour horizon vous n'écoutez pas la
réponse monsieur parle Christophe pour
le vaporison oui merci même présidente
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre solidarité d'autonomie des
personnes handicapées monsieur le
ministre demain le 15 février ce pour la
22e fois sera la journée mondiale des
concerts de l'enfant une journée pour
nous rappeler qu'en France ce sont 2800
enfants et adolescents soient un sur 440
qui sont concernés par un concert chaque
année ces chiffres nous montrent que
c'est l'affaire de tous et que cela nous
réunir pour tout à la fois renforcer le
soin pédiatrique et la prévention
améliorer les financements de la
recherche augmenter les moyens que nous
mettons à disposition des familles pour
surmonter le choc et la perte de repère
que représente un cancer chez un enfant
les concerts pédiatriques font de
longues dates parties intégrante des
plans gouvernementaux et la dernière
stratégie 2021 2030 en cours de
déploiement comprend désormais involé de
prise en charge des enfants malades et
de leur famille et la progressé ces
dernières années puisque de nombreux
dispositifs existants ont été améliorés
comme la création du dispositif de dons
de congés au profit des aidants le
doublement de la durée du congé de
présence parentale ou dernièrement
l'évolution du complément de mode de
garde nous saluons aussi l'initiative
récent de la CNP assurance qui propose
une nouvelle garantie aide à la famille
construite avec l'association EVA pour
la vie et la Fédération grandir sans
cancer qui vise à protéger les parents
face au crédit immobilier je profite
également de l'occasion pour remercier
l'ensemble des associations qui œuvrent
chaque jour pour accompagner les
familles et les enfants concernés
en effet les besoins des familles sont
encore aujourd'hui nombreux et les
améliorations nécessaires pour protéger
et simplifier leur quotidien la nature
exceptionnelle brutale et urgent de la
situation doit donc nous amener à
prendre des mesures exceptionnelles
réellement adaptées aussi à la veille de
la Journée mondiale des cancers de
l'enfant pourriez-vous monsieur le
ministre nous indiquer comment nous
pourrions collectivement aller plus loin
pour mieux accompagner la famille dans
cette épreuve je vous remercie je vous
remercie mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Jean-Christophe con ministre
des Solidarités de l'autonomie des
personnes handicapées merci Madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Paul
Christophe merci beaucoup pour votre
question vous rappelez parce que vous
rappelez des chiffres qui doivent tous
nous interpeller parce que derrière
c'est donner chiffrées il y a des
familles qui vivent des situations
douloureuses il y a des enfants qui
souffrent il y a des parents qui voient
leur quotidien parfois bouleversé il y a
aussi des frères et des sœurs qu'il faut
évidemment auxquels il faut évidemment
penser et soutenir
alors à toutes et tous je crois que nous
devons un accompagnement qui soit le
plus humain le plus sensible possible
mais aussi le plus adapté à ces
situations difficiles demain vous l'avez
dit aura lieu la Journée internationale
des cancers de l'enfant et c'est à
nouveau l'occasion de rappeler tout ce
que nous devons faire et tout ce que
nous avons fait en la matière ces
dernières années ont connu de nombreuses
avancées notamment voter ici dans cette
hémicycle et pour la plupart d'ailleurs
à votre initiative et tiens à vous en
remercier c'est notamment la loi du 15
novembre 2021 qui a permis d'améliorer
les conditions de présence parentale
auprès des enfants en permettant un
renouvellement immédiat de la durée
maximale du congé et de la location
spécifique je souhaite que nous
puissions aujourd'hui aller plus loin et
la proposition de loi que vous portez va
nous y aider elle encouragera notamment
les cafs à renforcer leur accompagnement
pour fluidifier les parcours des
familles et mieux protéger les mieux les
protéger des aléas notamment financiers
nous pourrons également y réfléchir au
travers de la nouvelle stratégie des
aidants et soyez assurés qu'avec mon
collègue François Braun nous maintenant
un dialogue constant avec les
associations dont je salue l'engagement
à faire progresser la reconnaissance et
le soutien des familles quel
représentent je vous remercie je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Monsieur René Pilato pour le
groupe la France insoumise madame la
Présidente chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à la première ministre madame
borne il y a maintenant 15 jours une
élection législative partielle s'est
tenue dans la première circonscription
de Charente face à un candidat de votre
majorité j'ai proposé aux électrices et
électeurs un référendum pour ou contre
la retraite à 64 ans madame borne en me
voyant devant vous aujourd'hui vous
connaissez la réponse d'une partie des
Français cette question c'est non samedi
11 février à Angoulême et dans de
nombreuses villes de France il y avait
dans le cortège des femmes et des hommes
qui contestaient votre réforme des gens
calmes déterminer et digne qui portait
une colère froide prête à exploser
madame borne loin de sa faiblir le
mouvement de contestation s'amplifie
vous avez donc perdu la bataille de
l'opinion les 8 centrales de l'Inter
syndicale sont prêtes à durcir le
mouvement en mettant la France à l'arrêt
dès le 7 mars le compte à rebours a
commencé ici dans cet assemblée vous
avez contraint le temps de débat afin de
ne pas discuter du fond à savoir le
partage des richesses vous vous tardez
vous vous targuez de ce que les riches
placent leur argent en France on peut
les comprendre monsieur Macron avec
l'aide de votre gouvernement multiplie
les cadeaux fiscaux et vous leur
permettez de se gaver comme jamais
cette réforme va les garder veiller
davantage cela se sait et cela se voit
pendant ce temps-là par vos choix
politiques le prix des aliments à
explosé le prix de l'énergie a explosé
le prix pour se loger à explosé les
pauvres sont de plus en plus pauvres les
vols de nourriture se multiplient dans
les magasins tous les indicateurs
passent au rouge madame la Première
ministre ma question est simple par
votre entêtement allez vous prendre la
responsabilité de bloquer le pays voir
de provoquer une explosion sociale je
vous remercie je vous remercie
top ministre du Travail du plein emploi
et de l'insertion
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député permettez-moi avant de commencer
comme l'a fait Thomas Meunier le soir de
votre élection vous avez aimé
félicitations républicaines pour cette
élection
et permettez-moi aussi
par ce même message de dire celui à qui
vous succédé ici l'amitié qui est la
nôtre et la reconnaissance de tous ses
collègues pour le travail qu'il a fait
ici
ce député vous dites qu'une élection
législative partielle est un référendum
je crois que j'en ai pas tout à fait à
la hauteur de cet enjeu là nous l'avons
dit avec la première ministre nous avons
une responsabilité cette garantir la
pérennité du système de retraite les
garantir la pérennité d'un système de
répartition la pérennité d'un système de
solidarité intergénérationnelle souvent
une responsabilité qui est de garantir
le niveau des pensions pour les
retraités et ce que nous voulons faire
avec cette réforme c'est cela à la fois
équilibrer un système parce que c'est le
gage de ça c'est de sa pérennité c'est
aussi l'améliorer l'améliorer pour mieux
tenir compte des carrières longues
l'améliorer pour mieux tenir compte des
métiers pénibles l'améliorer en
revalorisant les petites retraites des
nouveaux retraités comme des actuels
l'améliorer en faisant en sorte que
l'emploi des seigneurs soit enfin au
rendez-vous c'est le député vous avez
fait un parallèle
peut-être qu'il vous appartient mais un
parallèle entre la réforme des retraites
et des questions relatives au pouvoir
d'achat maintenant que vous êtes là et
pour reprendre les propos de branaud
lumière de Bruno Le Maire tout à l'heure
associer vos votes aux initiatives de la
majorité quand il s'agit de mettre en
place un chèque d'indemnités et d'aide
au ménage pour acheter les carburants
assumez associer vos votes pour aider la
majorité quand nous défendons le pouvoir
d'achat des Français associe vos votes à
la majorité lorsque nous avons mis en
place la loi pouvoir d'achat pour
justement protéger le pouvoir d'affreux
Chad des Français nous avons monsieur le
député une chance incroyable nous sommes
dans le pays qui résiste le mieux à
l'inflation le pays qui protège le mieux
le pouvoir d'achat de ses habitants le
pays qui crée encore de l'emploi malgré
la crise et nous le faisons malgré
l'opposition résolue de tous ceux qui
vous entourent vous êtes ici désormais
essayez de faire aussi bien que votre
prédécesseur
[Applaudissements]
je vous remets parole est à Monsieur
Philippe Guillemard pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Madame la
Ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères madame la ministre le 5
février dernier le régime démola
prononcé l'amnistie de milliers de
prisonniers à l'occasion du 44e
anniversaire de la révolution islamique
de février 1979
cette décision intervient après quatre
mois d'arrestation d'emprisonnement et
d'exécution de nombreux manifestants qui
avaient réagi au décès de la jeune Massa
Amini à la suite dans son interpellation
violente par la police des mœurs est-ce
cela le signe que les manifestations
commencent à peser ou bien est-ce une
manœuvre afin de calmer les esprits
jusqu'ici la conduite du régime nous
fêtant vers la seconde hypothèse
ces condamnations à mort et ses
exécutions sont évidemment des
violations graves des droits
fondamentaux d'autant plus face aux
aspirations légitimes du peuple iranien
a plus de liberté beaucoup ici à
l'Assemblée ont choisi de se mobiliser
contre le sort réservé aux manifestants
en parrainant des Iraniens qui ont été
condamnés à mort par ailleurs certains
de nos compatriotes sont détenus en Iran
de façon arbitraire et nous imaginons
l'inquiétude de leurs proches à cet
égard Nous nous réjouissons bien sûr de
la libération de la chercheuse
franco-iranienne fariba adelka après 4
ans de détention
madame la ministre près de 5 mois après
le début de cette mobilisation inédite
de la population quel tableau
dressez-vous de la situation en Iran et
comment concilier les mesures à prendre
face aux actes de ce régime qui tue sa
population et le nécessaire dialogue que
nous devons préserver eu égard à la
situation de nos ressortissants détenus
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Catherine Colonna ministre des Affaires
étrangères et de l'Europe
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés guymar notre action concernant
l'Iran visa concilier deux exigences
faire face à la répression par l'Iran de
sa propre population une population qui
ne demande qu'à vivre libre et dans la
dignité
protéger nos ressortissants injustement
détenus irrégulièrement détenu par un
régime qui cherche des coupables
extérieurs à ses propres échecs
concrètement notre réponse à la
répression d'Iran prend deux formes
monsieur député premièrement elle vise
l'origine qui organise la répression
nous avons obtenu l'exclusion de l'Iran
de la commission des Nations Unies sur
la condition de la femme mettant fin une
situation aberrante et nous avons établi
au Conseil des droits de l'homme de
l'ONU une mission d'établissement des
faits qui permettra de documenter la
répression et constitue un pas
fondamental dans les luttes contre
l'impunité deuxièmement notre réponse
vise aussi des responsables de la
répression nous avons pris déjà quatre
trains de sanctions européennes visant à
ce jour 78 individus et 27 entités dont
je le précise plusieurs responsables des
Gardiens de la Révolution et un
cinquième train sera très
vraisemblablement adopté lundi prochain
lors de la réunion des ministres des
Affaires étrangères de l'Union
européenne
concernant enfin les détentions
d'arbitraire oui nos dialogons avec les
rangs monsieur le député j'ai à
plusieurs reprises demandez moi-même à
mon homologue iranien la libération de
tous nos otages par aura les par écrit
et pour la première fois les conclusions
européennes du 23 janvier dernier
demande vise la politique de détention
arbitraire menée par l'Iran car il
s'agit bien d'une politique d'État notre
priorité c'est donc la libération de
tous nos compatriotes je salue à cet
égard celle de fariba adelka je ne n'en
dirai pas davantage et soyez assurés que
notre combat continuera jusqu'à ce que
nos 6 autres otages soient libérés je
vous remercie je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Charles de Courson pour le groupe lot
[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre
madame la Première ministre ma question
porte sur la situation très particulière
du président de la République au regard
des droits à retraite
en effet le président de la République
n'est affilié à aucun des 42 régimes de
retraite existant et donc ne paye pas de
cotisation de retraite
c'est pourquoi l'article 19 de la loi du
3 avril 1955 a attribué aux anciens
présidents de la République une
allocation mensuelle de 6000 euros
cette situation n'est pas satisfaisante
lors du débat sur le présent projet de
loi sur le système universel de retraite
le mercredi 12 février 2020 j'avais
déposé un amendement consigné par mes
collègues Bertrand pencher Philippe
Vigier Michel Castellani Paul Molac et
soutenu d'ailleurs par Thierry Benoît
pour affilier le président de la
République au régime universel dans une
perspective d'exemplarité
le rapporteur de ce texte Monsieur
Olivier Véran avait alors déclaré je
cite monsieur de Courson vous avez
parfaitement raison mais le chef de
l'État s'est engagé à prendre un décret
visant intégré les régimes de retraite
des présidents de la République dans le
régime universelle la parole du
président langage et nous pouvons lui
faire confiance et le secrétaire d'État
Monsieur Laurent pierre travesti
appuyait les propos du rapporteur en
déclarant je cite le but est de montrer
l'exemple nous souhaitons que l'exemple
vienne d'en haut
c'est ce que fera le président de la
République le Gouvernement prendra donc
un décret
trois années plus tard se dégradent n'a
toujours pas été publié
ainsi ma question est toute simple
madame la Première ministre le
gouvernement envisage-t-il toujours de
publier un décret affiliant le président
de la République au régime général
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
vous le savez nous examinons
actuellement un texte sur la réforme des
retraites qui concerne chacun des 42
régimes mais une fois que j'ai dit que
cela concernait chacun des 42 régimes
existants vous savez tout comme moi
qu'il existe un certain nombre de régime
particulier des régimes particuliers qui
sont parfois régis par des décisions
relevant du bureau des assemblées je
pense aux fonctions publiques
parlementaires des régimes particuliers
qui relèvent de décisions là aussi du
bureau des assemblées je pense au régime
de retraite parlementaire il existe des
régimes de retraite qui relèvent des
oiseaux de lois organiques
c'est par exemple le cas des membres du
Conseil constitutionnel et puis il
existe des régimes qui ne sont pas des
régimes de retraite qui sont peut-être
pourrait-on les appeler des régimes de
pension des régimes prévus par la
République pour assurer une indemnité
minimale et une forme d'allocation à
d'anciens présidents de la République
défini par les décrets que vous avez
rappelé ce décret n'est pas un décret
que le gouvernement doit prendre c'est
un décret qui relève du seul président
de la République et je peux vous assurer
monsieur député le Courson que si nous
ne sommes plus aujourd'hui dans une
logique de création d'un système
universel ce qui renvoie certainement à
d'autres considérations le président de
la République a eu à plusieurs
occasions plusieurs reprises la
possibilité de dire combien en la
matière pour la période qui viendra
après la fin de son mandat présidentiel
il va ira être exemplaire il reste
quatre ans pour cela comptez sur lui il
a toujours été à l'heure il a toujours
été au rendez-vous de ses engagements
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre j'ai parlé
d'exemplarité
vous me répondez qu'il y a d'autres
régimes particuliers que le régime du
président de la République dont le
régime des parlementaires je vous
rappellerai que dans l'ancien texte il y
avait une loi organique associée
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Véronique louvager pour le groupe les
républicain merci merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la Première ministre les
républicains vous le savez sont attachés
au système de retraite par répartition
voulue par le général de Gaulle est
fondé sur le principe de la solidarité
entre les générations régimes par
ailleurs qui a été préservé par
différentes réformes précédentes les
réformes baladures Chirac Fillon ou
Sarkozy à ce jour la réalité
démographique menace l'équilibre du
système et une réforme est donc
nécessaire elle est même devenue urgente
le président de la république ayant
renoncé à agir sur le mandat précédent
refusons la baisse des pensions comme la
hausse des cotisations les députés les
républicains ont obtenu le renoncement à
relever l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 65 ans la revalorisation des
petites pensions et l'abandon du
prélèvement envisagé sur le système de
retraite complémentaire agirc-arco pour
autant il y a encore des avancées
nécessaires et nous voulons notamment
que cette réforme un véritable
instrument de redistribution à
destination des maires de famille qui
ont eu des carrières hachées par exemple
mais ma question porte sur une meilleure
prise en compte de la spécificité des
carrières longues pour que personne
personne ne batisse de la réforme en
effet enlevant l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite à 65 ans 64 ans pardon il
est impératif qu'une attention encore
plus importante soit apportée à ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler tôt alors ma
question est simple madame la Première
ministre pouvez-vous assurer qu'aucune
des personnes engagées dans une carrière
longue définie par la réforme Fillon de
2003 ne travaillera plus de 43 ans je
vous remercie je vous remercie ma chère
colog la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Véronique louvagi
vous m'interrogez sur un point essentiel
de notre projet pour les retraites et
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire dès
le 10 janvier lors de la présentation de
la réforme la prise en compte de la
situation de celles et ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt est un des
marqueurs forts de ce projet alors
beaucoup de choses ont été dites ou
écrites sur ce sujet y compris des
inexactitudes ou des contre-vérités je
veux donc madame la députée être la plus
claire possible
et je voudrais le souligner si nous
sommes attentifs à garder la cohérence
globale de notre projet à la différence
de certains dans cette hémicy qui font
obstacle au débat le gouvernement a
écouté et fait évoluer son projet en
fonction des arguments et des
propositions défendues par les uns et
les autres
la cohérence exige d'abord de rappeler
que notre système de retraite repose sur
le respect d'une double d'une double
condition d'âge de départ et de durée de
cotisation pour pouvoir bénéficier d'une
pension le dispositif dit de carrière
longue répond quant à lui à ces mêmes
règles en y ajoutant la condition
d'avoir travaillé 4 ou 5 trimestres
avant un certain âge nous ne touchons
pas assez principe et pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler le plus tôt nous
améliorons même leur situation et j'ai
eu l'occasion de l'indiquer il y a une
dizaine de jours nous allons étendre ce
dispositif à ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler entre 20 et 21 ans avec donc
une durée de cotisation un âge anticipé
de départ à 63 ans et la nécessité
d'avoir travaillé 4 ou 5 trimestres
avant la fin de l'année civile de ses 21
ans alors pourquoi avons-nous bougé sur
ce point
les 20-21 ans devaient atteindre l'âge
légal prévu à l'article 7 du projet de
loi et donc 64 ans en 2030 ce qui les
conduisait avoir une durée de cotisation
de 44 ans j'ai pris un engagement et il
donne lieu à un amendement du
Gouvernement déposé aujourd'hui pour
cette tranche d'âge qui pose le principe
que dès lors que est atteint l'âge de
départ anticipé la réforme ne prévoit
pas pour les carrières longues de durée
de cotisation supérieure à 43 ans ce
sera donc aussi le cas pour les
personnes qui ont commencé à travailler
à 17 ans et dont l'âge de départ
anticipé est fixé à 60 ans madame la
députée je suis attaché au principe des
carrières longues qui ont été affixées à
l'époque dans une réforme portée vous le
savez par François Fillon je suis
attaché plus globalement aux règles de
notre système de retraite fondé sur un
double critère d'âge de départ et de
durée de cotisation
je suis attaché par dessus tout à la
viabilité de notre système de retraite
par répartition et c'est par précisément
pour ça que je pense qu'il est
indispensable d'en assurer l'équilibre
je mesure ce que cela représente pour
chacun de nos concitoyens pour chaque
Français dans sa vie quotidienne le
débat parlementaire est précieux pour
éclairer ses enjeux et le travail qui
sera fait sur ses décrets sera conduit
dans la transparence nous proposerons à
des parlementaires de chaque groupe d'y
être associés alors oui dans une réforme
comme celle-ci des points qui peuvent
paraître techniques ou secondaires
pardon qui peuvent paraître technique ne
sont pas secondaires et les
simplifications sont rapidement
mensongères j'assume que mon
gouvernement et moi-même ayant toujours
des expressions précises sans doute trop
peu lyriques au goût de certains pour
parler de cette réforme c'est la
condition de la vérité et je nie
dérogerai pas je vous remercie
madame
la ministre madame louvager merci madame
la Présidente merci madame la Première
ministre pour ces réponses je crois que
nous sommes tous attachés à avoir
effectivement un mixte du relèvement de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite et
une prise en compte de la durée de
cotisation parce qu'il nous faut prendre
en compte que le plus souvent les
métiers qui sont débutés tôt sont des
métiers qui sont physiquement exposés
donc je pense qu'il est très important
que nous puissions en faire en sorte que
toutes les personnes qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 20 ans puisse être
reconnu et avoir une réforme juste et
équilibrée merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Lisette Pollet
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre du
travail et du plein emploi monsieur le
ministre s'occupait d'un parent à valide
ou d'un enfant handicapé à domicile a
généralement des conséquences
importantes sur la carrière en 2021 un
français sur 6 s'occupait d'un proche
malade âgé ou handicapé or du fait du
vieillissement de la population la
nécessité des aidants va se faire de
plus en plus criante depuis 2014 les
proches aidants bénéficient d'un
trimestre de majoration par période de
30 mois dans la limite de 8 trimestres
votre élargissement de validation des
trimestres à un plus grand nombre des
dents est une bonne chose mais pourquoi
limiter la proratisation à quatre
trimestres aujourd'hui la solidarité
nationale ne relais pas encore
suffisamment la solidarité familiale
dans le contexte actuel de pénurie de
professionnels de nombreux proches
deviennent aidants à défaut de
meilleures solutions votre réforme ne
parvient pas à prendre en compte la
réalité de la situation des aidants ils
sont exposés à la fois à une usure à des
carrières très hachées ou arrêter
précocément c'est le cas de plusieurs
parents dans la Drôme qui doivent
aménager leur temps de travail pour
s'occuper de leurs proches il est
indispensable monsieur le ministre de
reconnaître les efforts qu'il
fournissent et de réviser les critères
d'attribution de l'assurance vieillesse
aidant alors qu'attendez-vous pour
reconnaître l'investissement de tous ces
aidants qu'attendez-vous pour porter la
majorité la majoration pardon un minimum
de 16 trimestres je vous remercie je
vous remercie
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
au ministre du Travail du plein emploi
et de l'insertion
l'essentiel des réponses à votre
question sont à l'article 12 du projet
de loi j'espère que nous aurons
l'occasion de l'examiner mais cet
article 12 à plusieurs objectifs et je
crois plusieurs mérites d'abord pour
mieux accompagner les Aidants et faire
en sorte que les périodes de vie
consacrées justement accompagner un
proche malade parfois handicapé parfois
malheureusement fin de vie soit des
périodes qui soient mieux protégées nous
allons ainsi créer un dispositif
spécifique qui va permettre de
rassembler plusieurs dispositions un peu
épars qui aujourd'hui nuisent
considérablement à la lisibilité de ce
système nous allons aussi accorder les
droits davantage de situation des dons
notamment les parents d'enfants
handicapés qui bénéficient du complément
d'allocation d'éducation de l'enfant en
situation d'handicap ça n'était pas le
cas jusqu'à présent nous allons aussi
simplifier de nombreuses conditions
administratives qui figent des
situations et qui bloquent certains
aidants nous créons en réalité une
assurance vieillesse pour les aidons sur
le même modèle que l'assurance
vieillesse pour les parents au foyer qui
existe déjà c'est trimestres vont
pouvoir être validés ils vont pouvoir
être intégrés dans la durée de
cotisation requise pour avoir droit à
une retraite sans décote ils vont
pouvoir pour une partie vous l'avez dit
4 peut-être que nous devons aller plus
loin mais nous commençons ainsi être
intégré dans les trimestres à la fois
pour calculer les éligibilité à
d'éventuelles dispositifs de départ en
si peu au titre des carrières longues
comme à des dispositifs d'éligibilité à
la retraite minimum à hauteur de 85 % du
SMIC dans le cadre d'une carrière
complète pour reprendre les éléments de
réponse que j'essayais d'apporter tout à
l'heure notre objectif est n'est pas
anecdotique il espère en sorte que avec
ce système d'assurance vieillesse pour
les aidants nous puissions accompagner
100 000 personnes par an 100 000
personnes par an qui vont pouvoir ainsi
voir des trimestres validées et ainsi
voir leur engagement être non pas
récompensé parce qu'ils ne le font pas
pour être récompensés mais être reconnu
et parfois être compensé pour
l'impossibilité que ça leur donne de
travailler de cotiser et de se consacrer
à la même vie professionnelle que tout
un chacun un article 12 il aura très
certainement des débats des discussions
mais je crois qu'avec ce texte nous
avançons très largement dans la
direction vous appelez de vos vins merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Yannick au riz
pour le groupe Renaissance merci merci
madame la Présidente ma question à
laquelle s'associe Jean-Marc julesis
s'adresse au ministre des Transports
Clément Beaune monsieur le ministre
l'attractivité des transports publics au
quotidien dépend essentiellement du
service rendu en matière de sécurité de
fiabilité de respect des horaires et
aussi de propreté d'informations des
voyageurs d'indemnisation de facilité
d'accès de synchronisation des
correspondances en ce sens la loi
d'orientation des mobilités qu'apportait
madame la Première ministre dans ses
fonctions précédentes a permis
d'investir davantage dans les transports
du quotidien de faciliter le déploiement
de nouvelles solutions pour permettre à
tous de se déplacer et aussi d'engager
la transition vers une mobilité plus
propre aujourd'hui la multiplication des
moyens de transport se fait souvent au
détriment de l'aspect purement pratique
les titres de transports et les
applications se multiplient obligeant
parfois les usagers à jongler entre
plusieurs abonnements et services dans
ma circonscription rejoignent une
métropole telle que non tout
Saint-Nazaire depuis chaque commune
suppose de relier covoiturage bus ou
train et tramway avec leur titre et
tarification spécifique cette diversité
nuit bien sûr à l'attractivité des
solutions de mobilité collectifs
proposées la mise en place d'un ticket
unique à l'échelle nationale se
développe dans plusieurs pays européens
ce système fonctionnant à grande échelle
facilite le quotidien des usagers car il
simplifie et donc encourage l'accès aux
transports en commun moins coûteux que
la voiture individuelle est plus
écologique vous avez annoncé vouloir
développer un titre unique de transport
pour toute la France et avait lancé pour
cela un hackathon les 7 et 8 février
dernier mobilisant l'ensemble des
acteurs afin de faire émerger des
solutions concrètes pouvez-vous nous
préciser à quelle échéance avec quel
financement et sous quelle forme
pourrait se concrétiser ce titre unique
de transport
[Applaudissements]
chargé de transport
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Henry monsieur le Président zoulesi je
vous remercie de mettre l'accent sur
cette question très importante du
fonctionnement de nos transports publics
quand nous parlons de transport de
mobilité nous le savons nous parlons
souvent le grand projet d'investissement
d'infrastructures et à cet égard nous
aurons l'occasion d'en reparler dans les
prochaines semaines sans l'outils même
puisque sous l'autorité du député David
Valence le Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures a préparé un rapport
transpartisan sur les investissements
qui sera très prochainement remis à
madame la Première ministre mais nous
devons aussi avoir une attention
particulière et c'est parfois un
changement culturel pour l'ensemble des
collectivités des opérateurs publics et
pour l'État lui-même sur des petites
choses du quotidien qui sont souvent
négligées l'information la propreté
évidemment la sécurité l'accessibilité
l'accessibilité de nos transports
publics vous l'avez à juste titre
rappelé et la loi d'orientation des
mobilités qui étaient extrêmement
importantes à cet égard a permis les
avancées dans ce domaine mais nous
devons sans doute dans cet esprit aller
plus loin c'est exactement la raison
pour laquelle j'ai proposer de lancer un
chantier sur un titre unique de
transport je l'ai fait de manière
partenariale en proposant aux gares en
proposant la région de France à d'autres
associations le collectivité de lancer
ce chantier ce travail ensemble il y a
quelques jours je l'ai fait en ayant
aussi le souci de l'innovation française
et de nos jeunes entreprises et c'est
dans cet esprit que nous avons organisé
un premier forum de l'innovation à les
transports la semaine dernière avec
plusieurs milliers de participants avec
plus de 70 opérateurs publics privés
grands petits des collectivités qui ont
proposé des solutions et nous avons le
sélectionner d'ores et déjà
collectivement avec les associations
d'élus deux solutions françaises
collectives associant tous ces acteurs
pour que d'ici la fin de l'année pour
répondre précisément à votre question
nous ayons les propositions précises qui
ne mettent personne de côté des
solutions numériques mais aussi des
solutions papier ou des titres de
transport matériel pour que il n'y ait
pas d'exclusion en la matière au
contraire c'est un financement que nous
porterons pour cette phase
d'accompagnement du côté de l'État pour
que à la fin de l'année nous puissions
vous donner les échéances plus précises
en deux ans nous pouvons le faire j'en
ai la conviction parce que d'autres pays
européens l'ont fait nous avons tous les
atouts pour le réussir et nous le ferons
ensemble
[Applaudissements]
c'est beaucoup Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Loïc Prudhomme
pour le groupe la France insoumise
merci présidente messieurs les ministres
de l'Agriculture et de l'Intérieur
pollution persistante de l'eau de l'air
et des sols bouleversement des
écosystèmes impact sur la biodiversité
disparition 80% de population d'insectes
en 30 ans en particulier des abeilles et
de 30% des oiseaux c'est le bilan des
pesticides pour notre environnement
bilan documenté dans un rapport
scientifique commun inrae Ifremer cancer
lymphome maladie de Parkinson stérilité
malformation troubles cognitifs
pathologie respiratoire c'est le bilan
des pesticides pour notre santé bilan
documenté dans deux rapports
scientifiques de l'Inserm alors des
citoyens des militants associatifs des
agriculteurs des scientifiques se
mobilisent pour protéger notre santé et
notre environnement pour sortir de cet
impasse d'une agriculture chimique quand
dans le marais poitevin il dénonce la
caparment de la ressource en eau vous
inventez la cellule de gendarmerie
Demeter vous mobilisez sans délai des
milliers de gendarmes des caméras de
surveillance des traces sur GPS des
écoutes téléphoniques des comparutions
immédiates alors ma question est simple
allez-vous mobiliser les mêmes moyens
pour arrêter et remettre à la justice
les trois personnes qui ont lâchement
agressé le 30 janvier dernier
l'agriculteur Paul François à qui
j'adresse tout mon soutien au nom de mon
groupe Paul François et cette
agriculteur qui après 15 ans de
procédure à fécondé Bayern Monsanto pour
intoxication il a été ligoté et obligé à
boire une substance inconnue par trois
personnes qui l'ont menacé et violenté
clairement en lien avec son combat
contre les firmes chimiques messieurs
les ministres combien de temps pour une
réaction de votre part et la
mobilisation des moyens indispensables
pour que l'impunité de cette agression
ne soit pas une option envisageable
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente de Monsieur
député je crois que avec le ministre de
l'Agriculture on peut évidemment que
comme vous condamnez les violences
contre cette agriculteur qui a en effet
été victime d'une agression à son
domicile à Bernacle le 30 janvier
dernier il a un effet comme vous l'avez
dit était ligoté et par un ou plusieurs
individus il a été fortement menacé et
oui la justice a été saisie de l'enquête
la confié à la brigade de recherche de
Confolens sur l'autorité du parquet
d'Angoulême la recherche évidemment de
ses agresseurs et on pourrait en effet
tout à fait imaginer que vous l'avez
fait même si aujourd'hui évidemment
l'enquête judiciaire de la pas conclu
que ce serait en lien avec ses prises de
position publique contre l'industrie
agroalimentaire et notamment la firme
Monsanto qu'il a fait condamner après
avoir été intoxiqué intoxiqué pardon par
un herbicide il est évident que le
gouvernement condamne de cette agression
je voudrais vous dire Monsieur le Député
mais vous le savez c'est plusieurs fois
que je dis notamment le groupe politique
qui appartient à l'autorité judiciaire
de mener les enquêtes et de saisir les
moyens de police et gendarmerie qui
souhaites évidemment les services du
ministères de l'Intérieur sont
totalement à la disposition comme le
prévoit la constitution de la justice
par ailleurs les patrouilles autour de
son domicile ont été accentués même
gardé son domicile et sa ferme ont été
gardées par les services du ministère de
l'Intérieur donc il n'y a pas de poids
de mesure tout agriculteur qui se fait
agresser quel que soit la cause et
évidemment protégée par les services
ministères de l'Intérieur et vous aurez
constaté par une enquête indépendante
avec la mise à justice qui pourrait
répondre à vos questions si vous lui
posez la question sur la conclusion de
l'enquête ce qui n'arrivera j'imagine
dans quelques semaines avec le travail
des gendarmes merci à vous merci
beaucoup monsieur le minet comme
monsieur le ministre vous a mis moins de
trois heures pour traiter des
manifestants des causes terroristes
combien d'heures mettez-vous pour
qualifier de phyto-terroriste c'est
fansitique c'est fanatique pro Monsanto
prêt-à-tout pour faire taire les
lanceurs d'alerte je remercie monsieur
le ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur député je crois que chacun
verra que même lorsque vous posez une
question qui évidemment méritée
amplement d'être posée vu la gravité des
situations et que la réponse du gourmand
est constructive vous n'empêchez
malheureusement pas la polémique et pas
la construction pour le bien-être de nos
concitoyens peut-être auriez-vous vu
peut-être auriez-vous vu une différence
entre l'ordre public qui aurait du
ministre intérieur et les enquêtes qui
relèvent du ministre de la Justice je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur François Jolivet
pour le groupe horizon si merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur mise du travail de l'emploi et
de l'insertion monsieur le ministre
Lindsay nous apprend aujourd'hui une
bonne nouvelle le taux de chômage du
quatrième trimestre 2022 enregistré
encore une baisse il est de 7,2% de la
population active et c'est le plus bas
niveau depuis la seconde en fait depuis
40 ans et nous ne pouvons tous imaginer
nous en réjouir quelle que soit les
bancs sur lesquels nous sions
comme quoi la courbe de chômage peut
s'inverser même après une crise covid et
une guerre aujourd'hui en Ukraine qui
place le prix d'une énergie au prix que
nous connaissons tous son inversion
d'ailleurs est d'ailleurs aussi une
bonne nouvelle pour le financement de
nos retraites cette nouvelle baisse du
chômage et son que la preuve que notre
économie résiste en raison des
employeurs qu'ils soient publics ou
privés mais c'est aussi sans doute la
preuve que l'emploi la politique de
l'emploi que nous menons depuis 2017
commence à porter ses fruits vous le
savez le groupe horizon et apparenté et
profondément attaché à la valeur de
travail nous sommes convaincus que le
travail et la garantie pour chacune et
chacun de trouver sa place dans la
société travailler c'est d'abord être
libre nous pourrons nous ne pouvons donc
faire notre la douce et attirant
illusion de la paresse qui en réalité
rend dépendant et enferme socialement
selon nous
nous devons donc poursuivre cet effort
important monsieur le ministre notamment
en direction de nos concitoyens les plus
éloignés du marché du travail l'objectif
est désormais très clair c'est bien de
parvenir aux plein emploi d'ici la fin
du quinquina pourriez-vous monsieur le
ministre nous dire qu'ils sont vos
prochains chantiers pour atteindre cet
objectif
je vous remercie le ministre du Travail
du Pôle emploi et de l'insertion
Lindsay livré une bonne nouvelle ce
matin au quatrième trimestre de l'année
2022 le taux de chômage a légèrement
baissé puisqu'il est passé de 7,2 à 7,3
% c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est le plus
bateau depuis 40 ans et ça se traduit
aussi par une baisse du taux de chômage
des plus jeunes des moins de 25 ans d'un
point qui retrouve son taux de chômage
le plus bas pour les moins de 25 ans
depuis le début des années 2000 cela
vient se conjuguer à d'autres bonnes
nouvelles d'autres bonnes nouvelles dans
le sens où le taux d'activité des
Français âgés de 15 à 64 ans n'a jamais
été aussi élevé nous sommes 68,5% à
travailler et puis il y a encore une
bonne nouvelle parce qu'il faut savoir
les souligner quand elles sont là c'est
que les emplois qui ont été créés au
cours du deuxième semestre de l'année
2022 sont pour tous les CDD tous les
contrats de plus d'un mois pardon des
CDI pour 52% d'entre eux et ainsi nous
avons atteint pour la première fois
depuis une quarantaine d'années aussi un
taux de CDI dans l'emploi global qui a
dépassé les 50%.
j'ai demandé il y a quelques semaines au
partenaires sociaux d'ouvrir une
négociation autour du partage de la
valeur cette négociation aboutit
aujourd'hui un accord a été trouvé il
était encore signature et nous serons
transcrire pour revaloriser le travail
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Yannick monnaie
pour le groupe GD
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre nous avons appris
avec stupeur comme de nombreux parents
d'élèves enseignants élus locaux
l'ampleur des suppressions de postes
prévues pour la carte scolaire 2023
sur le territoire national ce n'est pas
moins de 1117 postes du premier degré
que vous prévoyez de supprimer à peine
compensé par les 450 postes
d'enseignants stagiaires ce qui conduit
à 667 suppressions de moyens
d'enseignement pour la rentrée scolaire
2023 et ces suppressions se font de
façon brutale bien souvent sans
concertation avec les élus locaux dans
mon seul département de l'Allier 29
suppressions quand en Seine-Saint-Denis
sur la seule ville de Saint-Denis ce
sont 22 suppressions ou dans le
Pas-de-Calais avec 73 suppressions de
moyens éducatifs les conséquences de ce
désengagement de l'État sont
désastreuses pour les familles pour les
enfants pour la communauté éducative
tout comme pour l'éducation prioritaire
c'est un choix purement politique que de
contraindre les moyens dédiés à
l'enseignement alors que dans le même
temps votre gouvernement n'hésite pas à
augmenter de 50% les budgets de l'armée
nos campagnes et nos quartiers ont déjà
connu le départ de temps de service
public votre rôle n'est pas d'organiser
le déclin de certains territoires mais
de garantir leur attractivité de plus
les fermetures sonnent comme une
trahison faite aux élus locaux et aux
communes que vous étiez bien content de
trouver pour gérer la crise covid mais
c'est aussi un gaspillage compte ici
d'érable d'argent public puisque bon
nombre de ces fermetures interviennent
après des investissements de
réhabilitation d'école financé par les
collectivités et l'État lui-même la
baisse du nombre d'enfants ne peut
justifier cette gagie d'ailleurs la
France est le pays de l'Union européenne
où il y a le plus d'enfants par classe
monsieur le ministre il est urgent de
remettre l'école au milieu du village et
du quartier ma question êtes-vous prêt à
un moratoire pour suspendre
immédiatement cette carte scolaire 2023
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur papenda ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Monet le contexte démographique que
j'évoquais précédemment n'a pas changé
depuis une heure à savoir moins 500
mille élèves dans l'espace du
quinquennat en ce qui concerne votre
département de l'Allier nous aurons
moins
562 élèves à la rentrée 2023 des
modifications de la carte scolaire sont
donc prévues et elles sont discutées
actuellement avec les élus y compris
avec les parlementaires puisque vous
avez été reçus je crois par la
directrice académique en tenant compte
de cela nous faisons de telle sorte
aussi que le taux d'encadrement
s'améliore en d'autres termes le ratio
entre professeurs et élèves s'améliorent
y compris dans votre département de
l'Allier pour le premier degré des
ajustements vont être encore opérées
d'ici au mois de juin et également au
mois d'août quelques jours avant la
rentrée scolaire ces ajustements feront
que et font que le schéma qui est
actuellement présenté n'est pas encore
définitif je vais regarder en
particulier les situations les plus
problématiques y compris dans les
départements ruraux comme le vôtre
département avec une attention
particulière pour les situations
d'éloignement le gouvernement est
attentif aux situations rurales vous
n'avez pas le monopole de ces situations
nous y sommes aussi attentifs que vous
nous fermons des classes bien entendu en
tenant compte de la baisse des effectifs
scolaires mais nous le faisons avec
discernement et en collaboration avec
les élus locaux
avec qui
j'échange de manière très régulière je
peux vous le garantir et nous allons le
faire d'ici au mois de juin je vous
remercie beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur Monet
pour les élus locaux le compte n'y est
pas et quand on veut faire de
l'enseignement de qualité monsieur le
ministre on ne gère pas l'école avec des
chiffres et des ratios
je vous remercie
la parole est à me tenir Nicolas Thierry
pour le groupe écologiste merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur dans
la continuité de la question de mon
collègue prud'hommes le 30 janvier
dernier à son domicile le céréalier
charentier Paul François a été
violemment agressé trois hommes cagoulés
en ligoté frappé attaché à son véhicule
et obligé avaler un liquide Paul
François est un symbole empoisonné par
l'herbicide l'asso il fait condamné
Monsanto le géant des pesticides après
15 ans de combat judiciaires il mérite
le soutien de la représentation
nationale de quel bord politique qu'on
soit nul ne peut cautionner la violence
de ces agresseurs
c'est agresseur aurait prononcer ces
mots on en a marre de t'entendre à la
télé l'objectif est clair dissuader
faire régner le silence par la terreur
Paul François a évidemment notre soutien
lui dans la maladie a inscrit dans sa
chair les stigmates des pesticides lui
quand martyrise encore pour avoir osé
dire tout haut une vérité qui dérange
les intérêts des lobbys agro-industriels
nous devons réaffirmer qu'une autre
agriculture est possible que le jour
viendra ou le monde paysan se libérera
de l'emprise de l'angois industrie pour
défendre les vrais intérêts des paysans
et la cause de la préservation du vivant
ce jour-là nous nous souviendrons de
Paul François et de son courage alors
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur ma
question est double le combat de Paul
François est connu depuis longtemps
quels moyens le ministre ministère de
l'Intérieur va-t-il engager dans la
durée pour assurer sa sécurité et
au-delà de ce cas comment entendez-vous
renforcer la sécurité de tous les
lanceurs d'alerte et les préserver de
toute tentative d'intimidation merci je
vous remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Marc phénot ministre de l'Agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les députés dans la continuité
de la réponse qui a été formulée par
Gérald Darmanin vous complétez la
réponse d'abord nous partageons votre
indignation comme nous partageons
l'indignation et je crois c'est ce que
vous avez dit aussi de tous ceux qui
sont victimes de violence violent
physique c'est le cas de Paul François
violence verbale parfois violence sur
les biens et les outils de travail
parfois aussi donc on a besoin de se
mettre d'accord sur l'idée que nous
dénonçons toutes les violences Gérald
Darmanin a annoncé aussi à d'indiquer
aussi que les moyens de police se sont à
disposition que la justice est saisie de
grief très graves séquestration violence
en réunion et puis la gestion de
produits dont on ne sait pas encore la
nature mais enfin tout ça a été la
comment dirais-je la justice est saisie
et donc comme pour toutes les enquêtes
comme tous les pour les tous les faits
de violence il y a pas de tri
et donc pour lui comme pour les autres
diligence sera faite par les moyens de
police et par les moyens de justice pour
faire en sorte que personne ne puisse
être intimidé violenté à raison de ses
opinions et je pense à tous ceux dans le
monde agricole ou en dehors du monde
agricole qui a raison de ce qu'ils font
parfois dans le monde agricole c'est
simplement pour leur activité qu'ils
sont violentés ici c'est peut-être et
sans doute parce que le pour les combats
qu'il a mené mais moi j'entends bien
défendre l'ensemble des agriculteurs qui
sont victimes de violence verbale de
violences physiques ce qui est la
gradation supplémentaire et donc la
justice et la police seront au
rendez-vous pour faire en sorte la
gendarmerie en l'occurrence pour faire
en sorte qu'il soit donné droit à la
requête de la justice de trouver les
coupables des agissements pour que sur
Paul François comme sur tous les autres
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur
le ministre pour votre réponse j'insiste
sur la la gravité de ce qu'a vécu Paul
François au-delà de l'épreuve
personnelle ce qui se joue c'est la
possibilité pour des milliers de
militants de pouvoir continuer à lutter
pour le bien commun et ceci en toute
sécurité c'est à l'État au gouvernement
de garantir cela et c'est votre
responsabilité je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre
oui monsieur le député c'est notre
responsabilité c'est ce que nous faisons
pour toutes les personnes qui sont
menacées parfois des parlementaires ici
des responsables syndicaux là des
agriculteurs et nous le faisons à toute
voie et moyens parce qu'il n'y a pas de
démocratie si se répand et se construit
en permanence quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre de la violence verbale et de la
violence physique beaucoup plus grave
encore merci je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre la parole est à Madame
angélique rang pour le rassemblement
national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse aux ministres de l'Éducation
nationale une nouvelle fois le mois de
février ouvre la saison du remaniement
des cartes scolaires incluant la
suppression massive de classe et de
postes d'enseignants
monsieur le ministre c'est une véritable
source d'inquiétude pour les familles et
un enjeu vital pour nos communes surtout
lorsque les effectifs d'élèves sont
stables où à la hausse comme chez mon
collègue Emmanuel bléri dans le Pas de
Calais au sein même de mon département
de l'Aube les élus de nos communes sont
depuis des années contraint de proposer
des solutions de regroupement afin de
permettre la réduction des postes
d'enseignants affectés à leurs écoles
c'est ainsi qu'au sein du regroupement
de la vallée de Landion fort de ses sept
communes une école parmi les trois
restantes va fermer malgré les
investissements massifs communaux les
fermetures de classe tendent à se
généraliser depuis des années avec un
effet dévastateur en termes de vitalité
rurale l'avenir de la réalité de la
ruralité passe par des écoles et des
enfants
je rappelle qu'en 2017 le président
Macron affirmait que les territoires en
particulier les plus ruraux ne pouvaient
plus être la variable d'ajustement
d'économie sans surprise le président
Macron ne considère pas la ruralité dans
ses choix politiques ce qui bénéficie
encore une fois au grandes villes au
détriment des campagnes
de plus l'enseignement des fondamentaux
est en perdition le niveau des élèves
n'a jamais été aussi faible notamment
maté en français
et ce n'est pas en éloignant les enfants
de leur école ni des écoles de la
ruralité que cela s'améliorera ma
question est simple monsieur le ministre
nos villages sont aussi des zones
prioritaires alors allez-vous enfin
redonner des moyens à tous les enfants
pour que celui qui est né dans le plus
des petits des villages bénéficient de
la même qualité d'enseignement que celui
qui est né à Paris que comptez-vous
mettre en oeuvre pour préserver nos
écoles rurales socle de la vitalité de
l'attractivité elles sont les grandes
oubliées de votre gouvernement qui ne
pensent que métropole je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur pas peine
Diagne ministre de l'éducation nationale
et de la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
députérante le contexte démographique
que j'évoquais précédemment n'a pas n'a
toujours pas changé depuis quelques
minutes et donc dans votre département
ce sont environ 300 élèves que l'on
contrat en moins à la rentrée
2023 la dazen de votre département que
j'ai eu au téléphone à clairement
indiqué qu'il s'agit d'un processus en
cours il y a des ajustements qui sont et
seront fait d'ici au mois de juin et
d'ici au mois d'août nous tenons compte
particulièrement des territoires ruraux
en maintenant dans votre département
certaines classes avec des effectifs de
15 élèves dans le dans le cadre des
regroupements pédagogiques
intercommunaux cela montre d'ailleurs la
volonté des élus locaux de coopération
afin de maintenir des écoles de qualité
dans leur territoire j'ajoute que la
dazen a décidé de mettre en place des
classes dédoublées dans les territoires
ruraux de votre département lorsque les
indicateurs sociaux montrent une
fragilité
merci Monsieur le Ministre
madame Ranc
monsieur le ministre ce sont 17000
écoles qui ont fermé en 40 ans je
signale jusqu'à ce rythme ce sont toutes
nos campagnes qui vont disparaître je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame la députée les territoires ruraux
font l'objet d'une attention soutenue
dans le travail de carte scolaire le
nombre d'élèves par classe et plus
faible dans les territoires ruraux que
dans les territoires
urbains je vous rappelle aussi que le
travail actuel nous sommes au travail
actuellement pour
remanier la carte scolaire et je vous
suggère de la regarder d'un petit peu
plus près
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Liliana Tanguy pour
le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au secrétaire d'État à la mer
à laquelle j'associe mon collègue
Jean-Pierre Pons député de
Boulogne-sur-Mer et Bertrand sort député
de Grandville monsieur le ministre dans
la continuité des engagements du
Président de la République pour soutenir
les pêcheurs français vous avez lancé le
plan d'accompagnement individuel brexit
à destination des propriétaires de
bateaux de pêche dont l'exploitation a
été fragilisée par le brexit les
pêcheurs de Bretagne des Hauts de France
et de Normandie dont l'activité est
fortement dépendante des eaux
britanniques sont concernés notamment
dans les ports du Sud Finistère ce plan
doté de 65 millions d'euros visa
accompagner les pêcheurs que le brexit
compte à contraint à mettre à l'arrêt
leur bateau il doit permettre à une
nouvelle génération de pêcheurs
d'exercer leur métier dans de bonnes
conditions techniques et économiques de
nombreuses armateurs concernés ont fait
leur demande d'accompagnement pai et sur
150 dossiers déposés 90 ont été retenus
dont 26 pour le seul quartier du
Guilvinec dans ma circonscription qui
comprend aussi les ports de Loctudy et
de Saint-Guénolé ce chiffre au regard de
la flottille actuelle sur ce quartier
maritime du pays bigouden qui comporte
plus de 200 navires est important et
risque de mettre en péril le secteur de
la pêche bretonne monsieur le ministre
tous les acteurs locaux de la filière
sont inquiets car ils craignent une
baisse du tonnage débarqué sous crier du
Guilvinec premier port de pêche
artisanal en France cette perte impacte
les gros armements mais aussi les petits
navires ainsi que les entreprises de
mariage et les chantiers naval un emploi
en mer représente quatre emplois à terre
il y a donc un risque pour l'emploi
local très dépendant de la pêche qui
constitue un facteur très fort
d'attractivité essentiel pour la
sauvegarde de l'économie et de
l'identité du territoire ainsi Monsieur
le Ministre pouvez-vous nous faire le
point sur ce plan suite aux conventions
de sortie de flotte signée en France et
en particulier en Bretagne je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur beberville secrétaire d'État
chargé de la mer
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Liliana Tanguy comme vous le
savez le brexit a été un choc pour la
filière halieutique et pour la pêche
puisque 30% du volume de la pêche
française était lié directement à
l'accès aux eaux britanniques en réponse
à ce choc des plans de sortie flotte ont
été annoncés ont été préparés dans un
certain nombre de pays européens à la
demande de la première ministre nous
avons souhaité avoir une logique
différente d'il y a un an et demi c'est
à dire d'avoir un plan d'accompagnement
individuel c'est-à-dire de mettre en
oeuvre des mesures simplement pour faire
face aux conséquences du brexit et donc
très concrètement le plan
d'accompagnement individuel c'est quoi
c'est un objectif évitez que le fait de
ne pas pouvoir avoir accès aux eaux
britanniques fragilisent les entreprises
fragilise les armements donc fragilise
nos ports les crier et entraînent une
accélération de l'effondrement de la
filière pêche dans les hauts de France
en Bretagne mais également en Normandie
et donc c'est une enveloppe financière
ce plan d'accompagnement individuel
limité circonscrite à ceux qui ont été
impactés directement par le brexit nous
avons travaillé des critères très précis
certains nous disaient que les critères
étaient trop laxistes certains nous
disaient qu'ils étaient trop restrictifs
je crois donc que nous sommes dans le
bon équilibre et puis ensuite c'est une
méthode de travail nous avons construit
ce plan avec les professionnels de la
pêche avec les acteurs locaux avec trois
principes 1 la transparence sur la
réattribution la réalocation des quotas
et des droits de pêche de la
préservation des équilibres entre les
ports et les équilibres régionaux et
troisième élément important continuez à
accompagner à investir pour développer
l'économie locale la pêche qu'un élément
fondamentale pour la souveraineté
alimentaire de notre pays je rappelle
que d'un certain nombre de pays au
Pays-Bas ou encore en Irlande c'est 30%
de la paix de la flotte qui va sortir
nous sommes à 3% et donc voyez la pêche
en France elle a un avenir nous
accompagnons individuellement les
pêcheurs je pense notamment aussi aux
Hauts-de-France où il y a une saison
exceptionnelle et merci la mobilisation
de tous les acteurs notamment
Jean-Pierre pon et donc nous travaillons
pour accompagner les pêcheurs au plus
près et maintenir les équilibres
territoriaux
[Musique]
la parole est à Madame Nathalie Oziol
pour la France insoumise merci madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues je voudrais
commencer par adresser toutes nos
pensées au plus de 35000 victimes du
terrible séisme qui a frappé la Turquie
et la Syrie le 6 février dernier ainsi
qu'à leur famille et leurs proches
par ailleurs l'organisation mondiale de
la santé compte désormais environ 26
millions de sinistrés 5 millions de
personnes en situation de grande
vulnérabilité
nous saluons d'abord l'action du
gouvernement français qui a très
rapidement dépêché les premiers secours
personnels de santé et moyens matériels
comme la gravité de l'événement le
rendait nécessaire cette réactivité
rappelle l'immense compétence du centre
de crise et de soutien du ministère des
Affaires étrangères dans tous les moyens
et prérogatives doivent être maintenues
la France a maintenant un devoir
d'humanité d'abord celui de geler les
expulsions vers la Syrie et vers la
Turquie dans le contexte exceptionnel
qui est celui de ces deux pays celui
ensuite de faciliter le rapprochement
des victimes de la catastrophe avec leur
famille résidente en France
ces personnes ont parfois tout perdu
leur habitation leurs souvenirs leurs
proches et comme à chaque catastrophe
les conditions d'hygiène sur place font
aussi craindre des épidémies d'ores et
déjà le gouvernement allemand a pris une
décision qui doit nous inspirer il a
annoncé qu'il a les facilité l'octroi de
visa de trois mois pour les survivants
de la catastrophe en Turquie et en Syrie
notamment dans le cadre de rapprochement
de famille l'Allemagne contre la
première diaspora turque d'Europe la
deuxième est en France alors Monsieur le
Ministre allez vous comme l'Allemagne
renforcer le personnel dans les
consulats français en Turquie allez vous
simplifier les formalités
administratives pour garantir l'accueil
et la sécurité des Turcs et des Syriens
qui ont besoin d'être avec leur famille
qu'envisagez-vous enfin pour assurer la
protection des plus vulnérables les
enfants qui ont parfois perdu leur
famille et leur maison
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Catherine Colonna ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
au viol le ministre de l'Intérieur
mépris de répondre sur cette question
qui est d'une compétence partagée entre
nos deux ministères sur l'octroi des
visas d'urgence et face à la situation
humanitaire provoquée par ces deux
séismes nos efforts vont se décliner de
la façon suivante en fonction des
situations dans lesquelles se trouvent
les personnes dont vous évoquez le sort
en premier lieu nous allons faire en
sorte que les étrangers qui se trouvent
actuellement en Turquie et en Syrie mais
qui sont bénéficiaires d'un titre de
séjour en France soit accompagner pour
accélérer le retour dans notre pays
ensuite s'agissons des familles de
personnes étrangères ces journaux
régulièrement en France la question
appelle une évaluation conjointe entre
le mystère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères et le ministère de
l'Intérieur face à de telles crises des
crises majeures et ce drame est
évidemment un drame terrible la mise en
place de dispositifs Haddock tel que
cela puisse se faire dans le passé
parfois
est possible ça requiert toutefois au
préalable un examen attentif afin de
garantir un accueil dans des conditions
sécurisées pour notre territoire voilà
les premiers éléments de réponse madame
la députée je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est un monsieur Roger
Vico pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé monsieur le ministre selon une
étude de santé publique France publié
hier la hausse du nombre de personnes
souffrant de troubles dépressifs dans
notre pays et sans précédent depuis 2017
cette hausse plus qu'inquiétante
évidemment et notamment majeur chez les
jeunes adultes la population étudiante
déprimée à doubler en disant pour
atteindre aujourd'hui plus de 20% mais
aussi chez les adolescents 58%
d'augmentation des passages aux urgences
chez les 11-17 ans pour des troubles
dépressifs ou suicidaires on connaît
parfaitement les raisons de cette
tendance isolement dû au confinement
angoisses généré par la crise climatique
la précarité croissante la guerre etc le
budget total monsieur le ministre
consacré à la santé mentale en France à
vous y aider 110 milliards d'euros sur
cette somme la part consacrée à la
pédopsychiatrie est de 1 milliard et
demi d'euros c'est-à-dire un chiffre
margin
un exemple monsieur le ministre un des
centres de l'établissement public de
santé mentale de la métropole lilloise a
vu sept pédopsychiatre quittaient leurs
fonctions ces derniers mois 7
c'est-à-dire tous et la direction refuse
de recruter pour les remplacer tous sous
prétexte que ce serait je cite
contre-productif tout adulte qui souffre
de troubles mentaux a vu les premiers
symptômes se développer avant l'âge de
14 ans c'est dire l'importance d'une
politique qui puisse véritablement
anticiper ces phénomènes pour que nous
n'ayons pas à les subir collectivement
c'est dire l'importance et surtout
l'extrême urgence d'adapter les moyens
dérisoirs aux besoins immenses
envisagez-vous donc à court terme
monsieur le ministre pour faire face à
cette situation merci
la parole est un monsieur François Braun
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
merci mesdames la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Vico
bien entendu nous partageons au
gouvernement votre préoccupation sur la
santé mentale de nos jeunes concitoyens
et avec la ministre Charlotte cobel nous
sommes particulièrement attentifs et
avons gardé de façon très fine les
résultats dont vous parlez je peux même
malheureusement rajouter puisque nous
constatons dans les suites de cette
crise covid une explosion de suicides et
tentative de suicide particulièrement
chez les jeunes filles entre 11 et 13
ans sans pour autant que l'explication
soit si simple et que nous puissions
avoir comme cela des facilités de
traitement de ce problème alors vous
demandez ce que nous faisons et bien
nous continuons à agir sur les
structures qui sont en place en
continuant à les développer en
renforçant les CMP en continuant le
développement des maisons des
adolescents au moins une par département
voire même en développant des
dispositifs de adver comme j'ai pu le
constater lors d'un CNR santé avec le
président de la République près de
Poitiers avec un bus qui se déplace pour
aller voir les jeunes et les adolescents
au plus près de leur lieu de domicile je
rajoute également la mise en place et le
déploiement l'augmentation d'activité du
numéro d'appel suicide 31 14
si on considère le dispositif mon psy
également je tiens à vous préciser que
ce sont plus de 300 000 consultations
qui ont été faites avec une part
importante chez les hommes 25% sont
mineurs les femmes 15% nous continuons à
se déploiement et enfin comme je m'y
étais engagé les assises de la santé de
l'enfant et de l'adolescent qui sont en
cours qui rendront leur conclusion au
printemps ont un chapitre qui est
entièrement dédié à la santé mentale de
l'enfance sur lequel nous construirons
la feuille de route du gouvernement pour
les années à venir
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Madame Joël
maissemblement national
merci madame la Présidente le mal existe
crier Voltaire en 1755 dans son poème
sur le désastre de Lisbonne aujourd'hui
ce mal a touché la Turquie et la Syrie
et l'humanité assiste presque
impuissante à cette démonstration de
force de la nature je dis presque Carla
d'humanitaire et les moyens humains
influent en Turquie au crédit d'une
formidable solidarité internationale
concernant la Syrie Emmanuel Macron a
déclaré que cette circonstance
malheureuse pourrait bénéficier à
l'apaisement des relations avec ce pays
autour d'une assistante et d'une aide
effective derrière la communication
cette promesse d'un retour à la
diplomatie par l'action humanitaire
résonne comme un nouvel espoir de paix
durable car après la guerre civile et
une lutte acharnée contre
l'obscurantisme islamique ce pays
affronte sans aide occidentale une
kamalamité supplémentaire aussi face à
ce drame la France vient d'abonder à
hauteur de 12 millions d'euros aide
financière d'urgence mais cet argent ne
bénéficierait semble-t-il qu'au seul
population syrienne sous contrôle turc
alors même que les chiffres de l'ONU
nous donnent 13 millions et demi de
Syriens qui auraient besoin d'une aide
humanitaire et que les États-Unis ont
levés partiellement les sanctions qui
pèsent sur ce pays pour une durée de 180
jours six mois de trêve pour un pays qui
manque de tout des produits de première
nécessité comme le savon aux appareils
de dialyse si important dans le cas
d'écrasement des membres mais au-delà de
l'urgence médicale si nous laissons ces
populations face à la misère et la
destruction elles n'auront d'autres
choix que l'exil et le déracinement et
comme en 2015 là tu quirais la Turquie
pourra utiliser ses populations contre
l'Europe pour faire du chantage
migratoire à ce titre madame la ministre
les affaires étrangères la tradition
humanitaire française à cela
d'exceptionnel qu'elle a toujours
démontré son universalité nous
souhaitons aujourd'hui savoir comment la
rendre effectivement Syrie comment
garantir le retour rapide des ONG et des
humanitaire en France afin d'aider les
populations locales je vous remercie
madame la ministre je vous remercie la
parole est à Madame Catherine Colonna
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs d'été madame la
députée meylin les séismes qui ont
frappé la Turquie et la Syrie le 6
février sont dévastateurs et leur
terrible bilan humain est encore
provisoire nous le savons tous et face à
cette tragédie la France a été au
rendez-vous de la solidarité nous avons
été parmi les premiers à déployer de
l'aide alors s'agissant de la Turquie
notre mobilisation nationale a été
immédiate avec l'envoi de 140
secouristes et d'une équipe du centre de
crise et de soutien de mon ministère
arrivée le jour même dès le lundi dans
les zones sinistrées pour aider à la
recherche des survivants et des
cela par des équipes cinéphiles vous
l'avez vu
je salue d'ailleurs la réactivité des
équipes du ministre de l'intérieur et de
mon propre ministère au plan européen
madame la députée ce sont près de 1200
secouristes qui sont intervenus nous
avons également pu déployer un hôpital
de campagne avec 87 médecins et
infirmiers capable de traiter plus de
100 patients simultanément cet hôpital
est déployé sur les terrains et nous
sommes un autre connaissance les seuls
en Europe à pouvoir envoyer une telle
logistique aussi rapidement au nord de
la Syrie d'autre part les pertes
humaines et les dégâts matériels sont
également considérables nous avons
d'ores et déjà malgré les difficultés
d'accès au territoire syriens que vous
connaissez madame la députée débloquer
une aide humanitaire d'urgence de 12
millions d'euros vous l'avez évoqué dont
nous sommes assurés qu'elle ira bien aux
populations mais je vous rassure madame
la députée cette aide ira aux
populations syriennes en Syrie nous
sommes prêts à faire davantage en lien
avec les ONG de confiance et les Nations
unies afin que l'aide dumanitaire
concerne tous les Syriens affectés par
cette tragédie ils en ont besoin nous y
travaillons avec nos partenaires et en
particulier au sein des Nations Unies je
vous remercie je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Frédéric gainski pour le groupe
démocrate
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à Madame
Olivia Grégoire ministre chargé des PME
du Commerce de l'Artisanat et du
Tourisme
madame la ministre les formalités
administratives sont des contraintes
nécessaires mais qui pèsent sur
l'activité de nos TPE et PME
pour faciliter la création et le
développement d'entreprises notre
majorité a décidé en 2019 dans la loi
pacte de rassembler les 7 réseaux épars
de Centres de Formalités des Entreprises
en un seul guichet unique
ce guichet unique doit permettre à
toutes les entreprises quelle que soit
leur forme juridique et leur domaine
d'activité de déclarer en ligne toutes
les formalités auprès des différents
organismes que ce soit les services
fiscaux sociaux ou encore l'Insee
création modification dépôt des comptes
annuels ou cessation d'activité tout
doit se faire en ligne sur un même site
cette dématérialisation pilotée par
l'INPI est une bonne chose pour notre
économie alors que les records de
création d'entreprise s'enchaînent
toutefois madame la ministre tous les
acteurs nous font part depuis des
semaines de Lourdes dysfonctionnements
PagesBlanches impossibilité d'utiliser
certaines fonctionnalités et bug
paralyse la plateforme et contraignent
de nombreuses PME TPE et ETI à repousser
leurs démarches en bolisant notre
économie il y a quelques semaines vous
avez activé dans l'urgence d'une
procédure de secours en ouvrant
temporairement la plateforme Infogreffe
pour quelques formalités
certains actes peuvent ainsi aussi être
réalisés par voie papier auprès des
greffes compétents nous renvoyons 15 ans
en arrière
ministre délégué chargé des petites et
moyennes entreprises du commerce de
l'artisanat et du tourisme et du guichet
monsieur le député vous l'avez dit donc
je me permets de le répéter oui la
réforme concernant le guichet unique
elle est majeure elle est ambitieuse
elle est massive elle concerne
énormément d'acteurs d'opérateurs elle
fusionne pas moins de 600 de CFE Centre
de Formalités des Entreprises elle passe
de plus d'une cinquantaine de
formulaires papier dont je ne doute pas
que les entrepreneurs se rappellent avec
émotion lorsqu'on crée son entreprise à
un seul formulaire en ligne
et elle vise rien de moins que 100% de
dématérialisation là où aujourd'hui en
matière de création et modification on
est à peu près à 30% donc la marche
était haute et soyons clairs à 7h
mi-février quasiment nous avons
clairement encore du travail et la
satisfaction des utilisateurs n'est pas
au rendez-vous et à raison donc je vais
pas vous faire de grands discours pour
essayer de peindre une réalité qui n'est
pas satisfaisante à date je vais vous
dire surtout comment Bruno Le Maire et
moi-même avons un coeur dans les
semaines qui viennent de trouver des
solutions pour que ça aille mieux et
vite d'abord
d'abord
c'est dommage quand on fait preuve
d'écoute d'entendre ça d'abord vous dire
que quand même en matière de création ça
va plutôt bien on est quasiment à 80% de
ce que nous obtenions encore en 2022 en
matière de création on est à 133000
créations qui ont été gérées et qui sont
enregistrés plus de 80.000 d'entre elles
sont très concrètement enregistrées
validées et on est sur un rythme de
croisière qui est quasiment celui de des
années précédentes on a encore beaucoup
travaillé sur les modifications et
cessations d'activité et c'est pourquoi
nous avons d'ailleurs donné la
possibilité d'effectuer des formalités
de modification et de cessation par voie
papier nous ramenons 15 ans en arrière
pour reprendre vos mots monsieur le
député mais pour que les entreprises
puissent rapidement effectuer leur
démarche d'ici là fin du mois et début
mars Bruno Le Maire et moi-même en avons
pris l'engagement la plateforme
fonctionnera les services de Limpy sont
jour et nuit les week-ends
haute on va la gravir c'est encore une
histoire de quinzaine de jours pour que
ça fonctionne mieux je vous remercie
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la séance de questions au
Gouvernement est terminée oh c'est
suspendu